hey what's going on it's Bill bur it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning pcast and
I'm just checking in on
you I'm just checking to see how you're
doing how your week's going and all that
[__] um how was your
Thanksgiving you know there's a lot of
memes out there people talking about uh
not bringing up
politics a lot of jokes hey you want to
[__] not get invited next year bring
up politics hey want to [__] do this
you want have a good time don't bring up
politics that's good it's coming back
around again that's what you did you
didn't bring up politics you didn't
[__] bring up your gay Uncle you
didn't bring up uh religion you know
there was all kinds of you just didn't
bring it
up you didn't bring up the physical
abuse you didn't bring up the pain the
lack of
communication uh the walking depression
everyone was in you just didn't bring it
up right you put your face down you ate
your [__] food and then you went back
and you watch the Lions lose that's what
the [__] you did that's what
Thanksgiving was nothing was solved
nothing was
said you know at least in the German
Irish part of the
world sure the Italians they're more
emotional I'm sure something semi
personal was said hey you know
uh you know what I'm saying
right that's the uh that's the time I
grew up up in so I had a great
time yesterday and uh I've watched the
beginnings of two really good movies
this week and fell asleep like the
[__] old dad that I am speaking of
which thank you guys for watching old
dad's man it's been [__]
killing you guys got people out here in
Hollywood old Tinsel Town thinking I
know what I'm
doing
um I started to
watch um
uh the
grifters which for some reason I didn't
see it when it came out because it just
looked like a smart movie and I was like
that looks like a movie you're going to
have to think I don't like thinking
that's where my brain was at movie came
out when I was like
22 and then I sat down and watched it I
was like oh I really like this this is
[__] dark this is a good ass movie
and then I just fell
asleep this is pre- Thanksgiving dinner
you know this is like the Wednesday
before fell asleep to the grifters and
then last night night I started to watch
belly the uh Hype Williams movie with
Nas and
DMX and uh I remember seeing I saw that
in the movie theater when that came out
in the late 90s
long
long long time ago and
um I [__] fell asleep to that I kept
waking up because there was so much
gunfire in it and
everything
um but uh I don't know was that the new
segment for the dads listening to this
podcast what movie TV show or game did
you fall asleep
too it's always funny you know when you
fall asleep not in your bed you know in
your house you just KN off somewhere and
there's always that point right before
you open your eyes where you don't know
where the [__] you
are like if you opened your eyes and you
were like in the custody of a couple of
terrorists in the Middle East you just
be like oh
all
right I have no idea where the [__] I
you know I'm driving a car or at the
mall you know places where you wake
up um did I just shut off the recording
please tell me I didn't please tell me I
didn't okay it's still going
um yeah I fell asleep uh in the living
room on the couch last night and
um my lovely wife just left me there she
knew better I think she just know she's
like he's you know a nice full plate a
Thanksgiving in he sampled all three
pies there was whipped cream on it I'm
not getting I'm not moving this this he
is tranquilized that's what happened to
me but um that was a fun movie though
last night just watching how that thing
was shot was really cool but anyway how
about the [__] NFL this weekend the
NFL is just like [__] your marriage we
know what you
want there was three football games
yesterday God knows I didn't see him I
saw the [__] uh lions and Packers
that kid for the Packers got a
cannon I saw him running for his [__]
life to the r to the right throws it all
the way all the way all the way all the
way over to the other side of the field
the [__] ball was in the
air too long you know thinking like it's
going to get knocked down it's going to
get picked off nope
complete first down I don't know if it
was a first down but whatever it was
nice um three football games
yesterday there's a football game today
on Black Friday now everybody knows
today's the day you go out with your
wife you go out to a box store and for
some reason you put your life in
jeopardy you know over you know you look
at those box stores they it's just
nothing but
[__] everything in there is disposed
able [__] it's not worth dying I say
this every [__] year don't die don't
die over this [__] your kid doesn't give
a [__] at the end of the day I don't
give a [__] how much your kid wants that
thing what your kid needs more than
anything is your time if you give your
kid your time your kid is going to be
happy your kid's going to be secure and
feel provided you're not screaming at
him the whole time you give your kid
time your
time it's going to be fine and then the
fact cuz they didn't get that [__]
toy that BMX bike they always wanted
they'll be
driven and they'll go out in the
business world with a [__] a be [__]
attitude and they'll work their way up
the banking system or maybe they'll be
part of the war machine but you can know
that they felt loved when they were
growing up see there you go that's how
it
works there there's got to be a fine
line between giving your kid your time
and getting them you know some of the
stuff I wouldn't even say most of the
stuff that they wanted and not getting
trampled at a
Superstore I mean at this point you know
that that is a [__] option that you
know you're going down there and [__]
could happen
right it was like going to a [__]
soccer game in England back in the day
soccer a soccer
game in
England
um by the way you know I I love how much
they [__] pay attention to us all of
those [__] around the world the amount
of [__] that [__] F1 One race
gun it's just like what is the [__]
problem there's going to be cars going
200 mph through the city of Los Angeles
and somehow all of these people had a
around the around the world the world
the world had a [__] problem with it
it ended up being a great
race you're always trash in American
football we don't give a [__] about your
goddamn Sports go go do them nitpick
nitpick
nitpick rugby guys are tougher are they
fantastic go watch them have a good time
see
you I'll watch my sports thank you very
much I will watch Nascar I'll watch him
drive around in a circle if you don't
mind thank you thank you very much you
go have fun with your [__] Boomerang
and your feet and whatever the [__] it
is you
do whatever the [__] it is you do over
there I don't give a [__] what you're
doing have fun get out there and go do a
taian Roundup or whatever the [__] you
do in the bad lands I don't give a
[__] Australian Rules Football right
looks like a bunch of chain
smokers [__] at a rave or some [__]
right I don't give a I don't know if
that's what it look like I I used to
watch that [__] when I first got ESPN I
used to watch Australian Rules Football
and I loved it and everybody looked like
like they at at the very least had been
convicted they had at least one felony
you
know long
hair sweat I remember they would like
pick somebody up you know like that dumb
[__] people do at a wedding you ever see
that [__] who who does that is it Jewish
people they pick the [__] person up
in the chair every year there's a whole
compilations of Jewish men toppling out
of the chair at their own goddamn
[Laughter]
wedding you know somebody has gotten
serious seriously [__] up really
banged their
head maybe even a slightly concussed and
had to [__] shake off a concussion
cuz you didn't want to ruin her day you
didn't want to ruin her day
um I mean I got to be honest with that
when I see that thing I think it's a
Jewish wedding when I see some [__] I
look at that and be like that looks like
some dumb [__] that my people would do
the Irish let's get [__] hammered and
then [__] pick somebody up over our
head that's just holding on to a piece
of furniture we're not even holding on
to him what what could go wrong let's
walk out here with the lolium tiles at
the [__] VFW let's spin him around a
little bit and uh you got him you got oh
Mikey
um anyway uh yeah the NFL was just like
[__] your marriage this weekend it's
[__] amazing I also think they like
competing with the
NBA like I think it's I I get having a
football game on Thanksgiving you sit
down there should be one but to have
three it's just such a douchy [__]
move you know for a married person
because it's like I know everybody's
going to want to watch the dog show
there's the Macy Day Parade there's
another game going on right and I'm
going to be that guy just sitting in the
corner all twitching like I'm wearing a
wire you know and all other gangsters in
the room you all right there bill is
everything all right that's cool you
know just once once uh just wonder when
when this was
over what are you what are you in a
hurry or
something no no I was just you know just
curious open his [__] shirt and then
that's it that I'm in the [__] East
River
um and then the
NBA on Christmas shows three [__]
regular season games who gives a [__]
one one how about
one why don't you do that I like LeBron
on Christmas you know he's got the
beard right very Santa Claus
esque um all right I don't know what I'm
talking about anymore did you guys see I
got a buddy of mine last week one of my
high school buddies and he
swears he says the lock of the week
every week is the Iowa Hawkeyes under
he goes they got a great defense they
don't score any [__] points so I'm
with them in Vegas the [__] over
under is 27
points
27 all right just for you people don't
gamble I mean usually an over underwear
under I mean a low one's like
41 I feel 39 or something like that then
you start going like dude what the [__]
right um and the average I don't know
let's say mid to late 40s 27 so this
week so he bets it and it comes in he
hits he goes dude he goes I'm telling
you like eight out of 10 weeks they're
going to hit the under just [__]
throw your money on that and then you
know bet your other [__] and I was just
like laughing and he just text
me and the over under for the Iowa
Nebraska Corn Huskers game is the lowest
in college football history tomorrow
it's 25 a
half which is amazing to me not only you
know
talking a 13 to 12 game and then not to
mention when I was a kid when I first
started getting football cards I
remember Nebraska would be like playing
like Kent State and they'd be like 58
and a half Point favorites and you're
just like how do you not just take
[__] Kent State and be up [__]
almost 60 points and you'd do it and
then you'd watch these guys [__]
Turner Gill Mike Rosier Irving
frier Jimmy Johnson coaching the goddamn
team and they would [__] cover
be like 45 to nothing at the half you're
like what the [__] and then the final
score would be like 63 they always get
like
um this is the opposite of that in case
you're bad at math in case you are bad
at math
um anyway I got to get on my shopping
here my [__] Christmas shoing I got
to start that today after the podcast um
I did have a great week you know I took
a couple CLE uh people up in the
helicopter this week which was so much
fun I took my wife up for the first
time
um we had a great time she actually
filmed it she put a little bit on
Instagram I had like a [__] perfect
Landing set it down like a daisy and she
of course shut it off right before I
landed you know so you didn't see the
the helicopter hop at all or anything
you know or like you know
shake and
um I'm sitting there going like why
didn't you film the whole thing oh you
know I'm thinking about like Instagram
stories think like that was one of the
best Landings I've ever had but anyway
um it was funny you know like I brought
up one of my buddies from back in the
day on like Monday so him the helicopter
tour is all about stadiums you know the
Rose Bowl Dodger
Stadium um the LA
Coliseum and then you know we we
couldn't obviously go over where the
Rams are that's it's on like lax's
airspace right but he could still see it
and everything and then I bring my wife
up and I bring her around the rosebone
and she goes I want to see the ocean
it's like all right I get it so I flew
out there looked at some big [__]
houses all these crazy houses man um
that's something you know underrated if
you ever come out to LA you know they
got these helicopter tours out of
Burbank Airport um you should give that
a shot man because it's it's such a
great way to see the city and you see
some some of the sickest [__] homes
every time I fly no matter where I am in
La I will look down and be like holy
[__] is that a [__]
mall oh that's that's somebody's house
what the [__] you know I was over by uh
way out in the
valley and right along the 118 right
before you go through the Santa suzan
Susanna
pass north side of the street just out
of nowhere there I guess cuz they can
look out over the whole valley must be a
sick view but it's these gigantic
[__]
houses like stupid looking houses you
remember those houses from like MTV
Cribs when they used to like rent houses
and
pretend that they actually paid the
artists that made all those hit albums
you
know [__] travesty
anyway anyway plowing ahead um so who do
we got today we got the Miami Dolphins I
don't know who the [__] they're playing
I'm going to check that out I do have to
go Christmas shopping uh my my daughter
has out uh has outgrown her bike so I
got to get her a new bicycle before she
just becomes one of these computer head
kids cuz I like having them outside like
I did that yesterday um we go to the
playground and we [__] uh cruise
around my old truck and all of that [__]
just having a like I they got to have
like that
tangible stuff cu the video games are
are are ridiculous so anyways last night
I'm watching like Charlie Brown which I
really [__] hate that show I like the
music but I [__] hate the show
they're just so like the the really old
school ones they're just so
unnecessarily [__] mean to that kid
like the Great Pumpkin Charlie Brown
he's showing up to the houses and
everybody what'd you get I got candy I
got candy I got candy and then he's like
I got a rock like who the [__] gives a
kid a rock so my daughter's going it's
cuz they don't like his costume he cut
too many holes in the in the the ghost
sheet thing it's like well that isn't
that considered cute you'd give them a
rock they did like three houses
he got a rock every single time like the
even the parents hate him so I'm sitting
there watching
it and I forget who said what to him and
I finally looked at my daughter she's
six I'm like what does everybody hate
this kid and she says to me she goes cuz
he's a
blockhead or at least that's what
everybody on the show
[Music]
says I love how she gave him the benefit
of the doubt at least so I heard you
know the word on the street is he's a
blockhead
um yeah it's a it's a [__] difficult
show like I I have I don't know what it
is about that show like I have a real
hard time watching it is it because I
look like
him I'm not going to lie to you I was
watching it going like I could be him
for for [__] uh Halloween shave off
my
beard you know draw one curl on the
front of my head where the [__] am I
going to get that
shirt
you know they're going to you know they
must sell that somewhere
right black shorts yellow socks brown
shoes you always had shoes on it's just
it's it's a really it's a [__] sad
it's a I don't know what it is like I
used to watch it all the time and I
loved it I do like the part where Snoopy
acts like he's you know like he really
acts out the aviation he gets the
[__] you know the ruds going the feet
P I don't I don't what is it on
planes um he's working those as he's
going down the runway and [__] like
somebody who flew planes was drawn that
oh is that right bill is that what you
think is that what you think anyway um
so I'm on basically
vacation which means I'm writing
something um thank you to
everybody out there by the way that
watched the uh the club soda Kenny movie
trailer for
soda
right don't be a [__] and bring your
[__] to the movie that everybody's
talking about how great was club soda
Kenny I got it up on my Instagram page
that is something that we
shot um during the
strike you know and uh it was funny I I
put up all the money for it so I didn't
you know it wasn't a scab or anything
like that but it was funny there was a
few Union guys came up to the set hey
what's up what's going on here like I'm
like that's you know it's self uh
self-funded the guy's like oh yeah and I
was like
yeah
think I'm just [__] shooting here in
La during a [__] strike give me a
little credit I at least go up to
Bakersfield godamn it but uh club soda
Kenny absolutely killed
it um he was a
natural he was a natural so if you guys
give it a bunch of likes maybe we can
actually uh turn that thing into a movie
I think it would make a an incredible
uh
incredible
comedy and drama because we were kind of
melding Dirty Harry with the Naked Gun I
think it's a really good idea who knows
we'll see we'll see you never know
what's going to happen but uh and Bobby
Lee was fantastic in it and Adam Ray all
of these
people
um of course I'm I'm drawing a blank now
Jay Lassen is the
mayor you know we had a great time great
time so there you go so that's what I
learned from old dad right I did old
dads I learned how to [__] write and
direct and now I can make these stupid
little things that I want to make all
right I'll give you guys the whole
backstory well you know I'm thankful for
you guys you know for coming out to my
shows Look At Me Oh Billy pay pay it
forward um how that whole thing came
about was you know over the years I've
just been fascinated with Kenny's
background and him talking about you
know doing security and being a police
officer and all of that so I started
picking up on some of his jargon and
stuff and we would be driving into towns
to do a gig and I would start doing like
a gum shoe voice
over you know like it was 5: in the
afternoon in Carrie North
Carolina she was a tall drink of water d
d just doing that dumb
[__] couple of shits on the left like
how he talks and he would just start
laughing and then I just kept doing it
like At first just sort of teasing him
and then after a while I started saying
like you know we should [__] do
something
we should do like a [__] like a cop
series or something with you and he was
like I I'll [__] do it so you know
like most [__] you just say you're going
to do it you never [__] do it so when
we were shooting old dads you know
working long days and we were getting up
early and I had to act in the thing too
so I was like you know needed to get the
juices flowing here so I was I would
just start riffing with him on the way
down you know my brain was like at a
standstill I had a you know you know
started up so I would just start doing
that gum shoe [__] and I was just like
you know [__] this we should do this
right he's like all right we'll do it
and then I didn't have any time and I
was burnt out for the movie and then the
strike click came and I was like all
right I got time let's [__] do it so
that's how it all came
about and uh like I said club soda Kenny
[__] killed it it was funny the
people on the crew was like who is this
guy cuz I look up IMDb he's got no
credits he's a [__] he's a 60-s
something year old overnight
sensation the latest uh the latest hot
Dr um so anyway I
mentioned that I am
off until uh I go to
Vegas uh the weekend of the Super Bowl
so
um I do have to keep my actx Sharp
though so I'm thinking I'm just going to
do these Popin shows I'm I want to run
my hour like once a week
somewhere and uh like last year I did a
couple of I did like the tror and the
Roxy I'm thinking of maybe doing a
couple more places like that and uh just
like once a week just run in the
hour [__] around with some new [__]
like that's kind of the only way to take
it's the weirdest thing with like
standup it's like you can take time off
but you can't stop doing your
act or it just it's it starts shrinking
it atrophies you're like what do you got
right now oh man I got like an hour and
[__] 25 minutes you know if I took
six weeks off when I came back I'd
probably have 25 minutes be be like 50 I
would have to like struggle to like do
the hour so um got to get back into that
and uh who knows maybe [__] lose this
last [__] 10 lbs that I've just been
hovering on hovering on just cannot seem
to get over the goddamn hump I've had a
[__] this whatever this thing is
that's going around that my kids had now
my wife has it I it's been settling in
slowly to me but I've been doing this
[__] old wife's wives tail thing
whatever the hell it is just eating raw
ginger and then raw honey and then
drinking lemon
water and I don't know the older I get
the more I'm starting to think like if I
just [__] do that most of the time I
can avoid going into CVS and then just
wondering you know you know those cold
medicines those [__] [__] you
know I was changing light bulbs before
everybody came over for Thanksgiving and
I was I just remember when I was growing
up they were saying like you know they
have the technology to make a light bulb
that never [__] burns out you know
they just don't want to do it it's just
like why don't they just [__] do
that why don't they just because it's
all set up you got to keep making
[__] money oh God I'm not going down
this thing again like you know there's a
helicopter that they're working on I
keep [__] posting it it's literally
going to
change um helicopter Aviation as far as
like I think it's like a five passenger
and it's only like 750 Grand which you
know helicopters are you
know super expensive because of all the
moving
parts and anything
above a uh four seater Robinson
anything that can that can take five
people or more you start getting up into
the a Stars it's like well over a
million bucks so this thing's coming out
speaking of those light bulbs the main
rotor
blades um are just guaranteed for
life whatever the hell they're made out
of like you know the one that I fly is
like a two-piece system you got to check
it every day to every time you fly to
make sure it's not starting to separate
obviously that that would be
catastrophic and there's a certain
amount of hours you have to replace them
and they're ridiculously expensive and
this thing's coming out it's affordable
it's
durable um and it's on
Wheels which really uh fascinates
me because I was sitting you know I've
done a bunch of those fold downs and you
know you got to slide on the skids and
[__] like that there's always a chance
you could roll it over but I mean you
know planes roll over too but just
sitting there it just seems like you
could like the combination of both where
you could bleed off all that Forward Air
Speed when you flare and then level out
then you sort of do like a little bit of
a running Landing if you were like
landing
on like Wheels man that could be even
smoother I don't know it's just [__] you
think about you
know just stuff that I think about so
anyway
um I don't have any reads this week and
I don't have any shows to promote um I'm
going to have Joe bartnik on next month
I want to thank everyone that came out
to his shows in Pittsburgh he put out a
killer special this year and he deserves
to have people coming out to his show so
we're going to have Joe on next month I
got a couple more surprise
guests and uh I think that it that's it
but other than that old Billy freckles
is in town I'm going to go play with my
kids I think I'm going to go to the car
show this weekend for the I haven't been
to a car show in 40 years like the car
show like all the new ones
um I'm going to check that out I think
I'm going to go down there with Dean
delr it's going to be a [__] good
time and I think that's it um happy
holidays to all you guys Happy
Thanksgiving and truly I know I [__]
around a lot on this podcast but I
really appreciate all you guys like
watching the movie watching the club
soda Kenny F is for family my standup
specials coming out to shows and all
that type of
stuff um and I'm enjoying doing all of
this stuff more than I have at any point
in my career so uh if you live in LA um
I'll probably be popping up doing some
spots all right that's it happy gambling
don't fight with your wife like I did
this morning you're just going to
lose uh take the Iowa under I don't know
about this week though cuz I'm not going
to tell you I'm going to [__] jinx it
all right that's it go [__] yourselves
have a great weekend your [__] enjoy
the music and the bonus episode of the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
right after the music
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill bur it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday November 23rd 2015 what's going
on how are
you what's up oh Billy redface old Billy
red cakes oh [__] what are you doing
douchebag freckles here is uh in a great
mood he's on his F done with his first
week and not doing [__] I'm not doing
[__] for the the last week I already did
it I already accomplished the dream of
not doing [__] and this week I'm not
doing [__] right greatest [__]
holiday of the year everybody talks
about Christmas people talking about
Flag Day or [__] Easter I'm telling
you this is the one you don't have to
buy [__] all you do you just show up you
show up little corn beef and cabbage
whatever the whatever your little family
[__] dishes you show up you smile you
do a couple of air kisses you know feed
your fat [__] face and then you just
slip into the living room
right and watch the game sitting on the
sofa then there's that other guy the
socially [__] awkward guy who hides
in alcohol sitting in the Lazy Boy you
know you guys are angled just enough
that you can see each other in your
peripheral but you never say anything
you know couple times you go to start
the conversation and you see the lonely
guy being excited but then he [__] it
up and you see him withdraw again and
youy try to act like it didn't happen
and that's just the second quarter all
right
anyways
um I fin I did my official weigh in
today to see the damage I did I was
about a buck 65 or something before uh I
left to go to way back in September
right I was trying to get down to 162 I
got to
165 and one day I just skipped rope and
just sweated it out I got to like 162
point something but that's [__]
right got down to 65 then I had a
wedding a week- long family event and
then right after that I went to Texas
for a week and then Toronto and I came
back for a few days and then I went to
DC then I came back for a few days like
a week and then I did that two we
[__] tour of uh the Midwest came back
for three days then I did the Philly run
then I went to New York and then I did
MSG so in that time I knew I was putting
on weight oh I knew I was doing I knew
it I couldn't I couldn't stop
right all right now before I started
this whole thing I was 187 lbs I went
down to 165 I lost 22 [__] pounds so
the big question is Bill you dumb [__]
after you did all that work you stupid
[__] how much did you give back this
morning after weighing himself in
September before all the festivities
about 165 lbs I weighed myself this
morning right when I woke up the most
accurate weight from what I've you know
read on the internet so take that with a
giant grain of salt and sugar uh 1
76.8 Oh Billy what did you
do I just remember my last night in New
York [__] hammered eating two slices
of uh sausage pepperoni and it wasn't
even good and after the first one I was
like Jesus this is so much [__] on this
this feels like Chicago Pizza where like
nobody in near nobody in their right
mind ever has more than one slice of
deep dish pizza you're just
[__] you can't do it you're you're
out of your [__] mind so anyways um
yeah so I'm I'm pissed that I [__]
went that hard [__] it up that much
but I'm not I didn't see the dreaded the
one that really depresses me is when
that second number is an eight so I'm
going to try to do the
impossible the unthinkable Cleo will you
stop licking yourself so damn loud hey
Cleo
Cleo we we yeah you knock it off over
there I know you got to do what you got
to do you need a
bath
anyways the [__] was I talking about oh
I'm going to try to do the impossible
the unthinkable a There She Goes licking
herself again good Lord no shame
whatsoever I'm going to try to lose
weight during the holiday months here
I'm actually during the week of
Thanksgiving I'm trying to go my goal is
to be uh to do the three lbs that I was
doing back in the summer dropped three a
weeks so that's
1738 is when I need to be next Monday
morning when I roll out of bed and um so
we'll see what happens but here's a
[__] up thing I made three pies
yesterday all right um not all for me
obviously um just people come by the
house and stuff like that so I made a
cream pie a pumpkin pie and an apple pie
and I actually [__] with the sacred
family recipe piece now I haven't had a
slice of any of it yet but I upped the
cinnamon in my apple pie and
um and I used this this different recipe
it was a butter based crust and um my
wife sent me a [__] text message I
thought the house was on fire it was
just OMG OMG OMG OMG I can't even say it
that fast you [__] well say it slower
Bill we still understand she wrote OMG
like 50 times in a row so I was I had
gone I was driving so I texted while
driving of course and I said pie
question mark question mark house fire
question mark and then she did a bunch
of Emoji Emoji [__] and uh she wrote
that pie is [__]
delicious I said how's the new cinnamon
level she said perfect and then I said
yes with an exclamation point how about
that you got to hear my whole private
text
message no that's the best apple pie is
a
[__] you know I don't know how
you guys do it use like three different
types of apples you got to peel them
then you quarter them then you try to
get like eight slices right you slice
them nice and thin the way Paulie does
the garlic and [__] good Fellas and
you you got to you got to have your mix
ready though so they don't turn brown
you stick them in there you swish it
around and all that you make sure it
gets all over the place and then then
the [__] uh the apples all
intermingle you know what I mean like
like like the higher-ups don't want us
to everybody getting
along I'm [__] with you I uh guess
what I went down to the uh comedy store
yesterday for the F my first set since
uh my last show in New York and I went
down there had the best [__] time I
tried out all this new
material and I actually walked into the
comedy store and you know they have the
original room and then they have the
main room the original room is the part
of the original Club when they just
bought half of it it used to be a
nightclub called SOS and uh where the
original room sits I think was the back
of the main room so um anyway whatever
come out to LA just walk in take a look
at it so I go what's going on in the
main room and they go Dick Gregory I go
what they go dick GRE I go Dick Gregory
is on stage right now and they were like
yeah and I went in there the guy was
[__]
hilarious still funny as hell still edgy
talking about topical stuff he was
talking about Paris he was talking about
all this just right up to date
stuff um he was [__] amazing so that
gave gave me a charge so then I go into
the the uh the original room they bring
me up I start doing my thing
everything's going great you know I did
my little wage Gap gift I joke and then
I get off stage thanks a lot and uh all
of a sudden this
lady she comes up to me and then she
just wants to present her
case she's like you know well actually
I'm in my
mid-30s and now I I'm at an age now that
when I go out with a guy he he wants to
go dutch he expects me to pay for half
and then I just go well yeah you
should you know you
should I don't think it's asking too
much you're in your 30s you've
demonstrated that you're not a firstr
draft pick at this point you know you're
[__] up like me
so I know I'm [__] up I know you're
[__] up or maybe too driven to commit
to anything so you know we got to keep
each other at arms length here right so
I pay for my [__] you pay for your [__]
I couldn't like I couldn't even listen
to like that's that's your big [__]
complaint in life that for the first 30
years you got free [__] food and
drinks like as a guy do you know how far
back into my life I got him they get to
live like 8-year-olds remember when you
were a kid you just walked around as a
kid you had no money you went out with
your parents you had a whole [__] day
you ate you had drinks you [__] not
booze but you know cut yourself a high
SE whatever the hell you had you know
went to a ball game whatever you never
went in your
pockets the life of a kid you
know you essentially not like look I
obviously know women don't just not pay
for [__] anything but I'm just
saying that when they get
courted you
know you don't have to pay for [__]
generally
speaking right so anyway so she comes up
to me I just didn't want to [__] hear
it and uh I made the mistake I treated
her like a guy and I feel bad I just
completely I just gave her [__] and then
she was like ah you're being mean and
everything I'm like it's a comedy club
we're comedians this is what we
do and then she wanted to make her
[__] point and I just you know I said
all right and I just walked
away and then of course I made the
mistake of asking another comic I go was
I just too mean there and he's like yeah
no no comedian will never say you're too
me no said you know see about
right felt like the uh the right level
of
it um that's a pet peeve of mine I don't
like when I'm standing on stage and you
could Heckle me while I'm making my
point instead you don't you wait till I
get off stage and then you want to have
some [__] you know Charlie Rose
conversation about what the [__] you
think of the J I don't give a [__] at
that point I you know I would much
rather that you yell out during my
show like hey I'm in my 30s I got to pay
for a date that we could have had that
hilarious conversation a little back and
forth but
instead you know I got to get off stage
and then you come up to me like I'm
being debriefed after my
shift you know what I mean see where I
went right and see where I went wrong
like I don't want to [__] hear that
but you're more than welcome to Heckle
me I don't give a [__] I don't care
about that you know I'm up there it's me
and the mic stand you know I feel
safe
ah who's kidding who I was probably too
much of an [__] what what do you want
from me so anyways what the [__]
happened to my LSU
Tigers Jesus Christ I know I was on the
road a lot this year so I missed most of
the season but I watched the end of the
Alabama game they lost that game and the
[__] Wheels fell off then they got
their asses kicked by Arkansas who even
knew they still had a football program
out there I mean it's Arkansas when was
the last time you even heard of that
state Bill Clinton was in office and
that was only in the first term then the
former Governor A Little Rock
Arkansas all right and by the time he
got to his second term they phased out
Arkansas like the older brother on Happy
Days right no more Chuck now he's at
school now he doesn't
exist
right how the [__] do you lose to
them they're not in the midwest they're
not in the South they're just
there the name of their
capital Little Rock it's got little how
does he how does your Capital have
little in
it unbelievable we [__] lose to them
what what I mean what even goes on in
Arkansas some reason when I think of
Arkansas you know I think of I think of
like an Oldsmobile
442 like a 65 for some reason you know
they're riding around I bet they're all
driving around old cars like Cuba you
know like that embargo hit them real
hard too even though there's no embargo
on them but they're just Arkansas how
the [__] do you lose to Arkansas
um I'm just waiting for those [__]
Arkansas SEC people actually we [__]
7 one in the conference I don't
care and then who the [__] did they play
this past week uh old miss you know
right down there on the goal line and
one guy thinks it's a fake play the
other guy is trying to hand it off to
him was [__] Keystone
Cops Keystone cups this is what kills me
they'll probably end up getting rid of
Les Miles you know what I mean I love
that one bad [__] year and then all
of a sudden you don't know how to coach
anymore you watch they'll run them run
out you know somebody somebody's got an
answer to this nobody can just just be
like you know what we had a bad [__]
year it's got to be like oh you know
what that's it you're done you don't
know how to do this anymore does that
happen at your guys jobs you know what I
mean say you're working at Staples right
and you [__] uh you're going down to
the the aisle with the three- rink
binders and you think they're on the
left- hand side they're on the rightand
side then they go you know what you just
can't do it
anymore it's it it's over you've been
here for for [__] 4 years I don't
think you know how to work at Staples
anymore I know I'm I'm
I'm I guess I'm belittling both people
belittling that job and also belittling
the job of working at Staples I think
the job at Staples is the big thing is
you hide in the back room because they
have so little people on the floor if
you walk out on the floor everybody's
going to ask you a question right you're
going to walk out excuse me excuse me
sir
sir sir yes could you tell me
[Music]
where my daughter's eighth birthday
birthday's coming up and we want
different color paper clips you know
I that's when you should legally be able
to just grab somebody by the back of
their head and steer them towards where
they need to be you know and then like
push their head down to see where it is
on the shelf and then as you go to let
go you give them that little push before
you do that causes them to do that half
a step and put their hands out like a
toddler about ready to
fall
um anyways um I barely watched any
football yesterday uh I got a couple of
things done that uh were hanging over my
head that were going to cause me to not
enjoy my [__]
holidays
um I am now at the age that somebody
asked me to write a letter of
recommendation for this [__] thing
and I I just kept putting it off and
putting it off and I was like you know
bill this person is trying to get on
with their life here so I just sat down
and [__] forced all my ADD away you
know I opened the email but I looked at
a bunch of other emails first I
gradually closed all the windows and uh
I missed all the 1:00 games I caught the
tail end of the Cowboys game I was
psyched for the Cowboys how [__] nuts
is it that they're undefeated with Tony
Romo but they're 10 games in it's just a
[__] tragedy they were 2- 0 Tony
breaks gets his [__] collar bone
broken they lose seven in a row they go
oh for [__]
seven that Tony comes back boom it's
like he never left you know like that
old friend you don't see for 20 [__]
years and you see each other you just
start laughing you pick up right where
you left off Tony Romo Tony Romo you
know I want to hear the Cowboy fans
[__] about him now huh there you go you
got what you wanted you got Tony out of
the [__] lineup and look what
happened 0 for [__]
seven so now
he's back and what I love is the [__]
NFC sucks so
bad that they could actually go on a run
and still win the
division you know that's what's killing
me about the Giants right now cuz I I
told you I never want to see the Giants
again I don't give a [__] that we beat
them in the regular season thought it
doesn't
matter I can't I can't I I can't handle
another I could handle another Super
Bowl loss I can't handle another loss
the way we lose to the Giants and just
can't do it you know Tony Romo Fades
back to pass his shoe comes off he
throws the shoe by accident and
everybody goes after the shoe and take
he's running with the football he's at
the 30 to 20 unbelievable touchdown [__]
that I I can't I can't watch another one
of those John Brady back to pass he's
got to throw it [__] half a yard to
Wes Welker he drives the
ball I can't I can't I don't even want
to [__] deal with that and this is
what kills me the Giants who's
absolutely have absolutely [__] the bed
this year are in first place I think
with like a [__] you know four and
six record or something you know I could
just go on the internet I could look
this [__] up or I could just wing
it um no who's kidding who I would love
to play the Giants again as long as we
win you know to try to but I you know if
it was like going to be a 50/50 be like
yeah you know I don't need to go through
that emotionally anymore I really don't
[__] kills me how much these stupid
losses you know I never get a ring they
don't ask me to get on the duckboats for
the parade do they why the [__] do I
care why am I absolutely elated that the
Bruins have won two games in a row right
now huh I don't know I have no idea
second win big win against the uh
Toronto Maple Leafs I've been at home
getting caught up with them you know
they look all right last couple games
they look all right definitely up and
down season um so I don't know I won't
pack it in until uh like February and if
February they're still doing this stuff
then you start getting those awful
feelings like you almost want your team
to lose so they get a better draft pick
um but uh I can't I can't [__] do
that but anyways oh did I miss it
yesterday did the Islanders and
uh Canadians play Joe bartnik from Puck
off told me that there was going to be
bad blood was going to be some bad blood
in that game I think I [__] missed it
so anyways but the big game tonight is
uh put it is uh Patriots versus the
bills so um I'm going to try to do my
best to get in front of a TV so I can
listen to Bill's fans talking [__]
again uh about what they're going to do
what we should have
done right they're going to get all like
[__] we're going to kick you [__]
ass I already got a text from somebody
so one of my friends out there I think
the shred and Reagan show they texted me
going the Patriots are going to get
their asses
whipped and I just wrote back uh who are
they playing he goes they're playing the
bills this year's Super Bowl champion
and I just wrote back I said well it
should be a great game you guys have a
wonderful
defense good
luck just diffuses all of the [__] talk
why it's like why are you talking [__]
you know what I
mean dude they're going to [__] come
in there [__] he's going to do
[__] what if he doesn't and what if
he does
what are you going to do huh you going
to sit there and grow your man tits with
me you don't how to [__] do it you
know when I was watching the Bruins game
I was so disgusted with myself um I had
this workout for like the last two
periods every five minutes of the game I
would do 25
push-ups
um it's an easy way to do 200 you know
what I mean you get nice long rests
depending on uh how many penalties are
called in commercial breaks just every
five minute you bang out 25 I got to do
something guys I made three [__] pies
I'm in trouble here um but the key is I
haven't had one yet so I I don't have
the crack rolling around in my [__]
system all right here we go let me do
some reads here for this [__] week
and of course I got to type in my
[__] podcast my my password sorry see
that I can't do two things at once like
like the women can't like the
ladies um all right where the [__] is
it oh here we we go the old favorites
here we only got a couple this week all
right all right I got a couple of uh
couple of things I need to uh announce
here uh the fourth annual Patrice O'Neal
Comedy benefit I want to thank everybody
that bought tickets for this thing it
the tickets are selling uh faster than
ever and that just reminded me what the
meundies thing the stalking stuff it
makes a great stalking stuffer all right
um you get to see some of the top comics
in the country honoring the greatest
comic I ever saw live and uh honoring
his memory and helping out his loved
ones uh just going to be at the New York
City Center on Tuesday January
26th you know you just go to the fraking
website I'll I'll retweet the link once
again today I got the date up on my
website the whole damn thing um the
great thing about this great gift to get
for somebody and all you got to do go on
the internet click click click Bing Bang
Boom you're done stick it in the
stocking and then you can go right over
to spike in your eggnog all right and
then also
an old friend of mine has a new album
coming out if you guys like straight
ahead Blues someone that can absolutely
[__] shred on the guitar and has a
[__] voice to match Felicia
Collins um has a new album out called
Felicia Collins discovers the blues
Straight Ahead Blues album she sent me a
couple of the tracks me and bartnik were
listening to it the other night we uh
bartnik was over here watching uh
Chicago
Vancouver and um absolutely Blown Away
um for those of you David Letterman fans
uh she played in the uh CBS
Orchestra and uh she was actually there
when they were way back when they were
on NBC and um so obviously the show's
over and now she's stretching out so
check it out Tuesday Felicia Collins new
album The felici Felicia Collins
discovers the
blues
um all right and what else do I got
coming up I have um of course FIS for
family is out on December
18th and uh um oh and Pete Corelli is
going to be a guest on the Thursday
afternoon podcast just before Friday
next week to promote uh I believe his
new standup special on uh Showtime which
I heard is getting rave reviews he's one
of my favorite comics of all time and
he's a great guy to go and see before he
[__] blows up cuz he's that level
funny um all right and with that with
that
babbling let's march on here with the
podcast
um what was I going to say yes so I got
to I'm got to go to the [__] gym
today the second I do this so this is my
game plan I'm going to do an hour on the
elliptical today Tuesday and
Wednesday um I'm doing the Joe Joe
Rogan's
podcast on Tuesday tomorrow so uh I
might bring some of that pie that I made
over to him you know which would be a
cool thing to do for the holidays plus
then I don't have it around here so I'm
not [__] eating it right and then all
they do is eat one I think that could
work right you got to give away some of
it
um but I'm going to do yeah three hours
of
that by Thanksgiving my one bad day is
going to be Thanksgiving then I'm just
going to try to uh I got to turn around
guys if I go back up to the 180s I'm
going be so [__] depressed I just
don't want to be that [__] guy at the
start of the year like I'm going to
[__] here we go I'm going to [__]
get in shape you know you know what
that's like you know it's like starting
your year as a fat [__] who's got a like
[__] 20 30 40 50 100 [__] pounds
it's the worst why not get started now
and not do the [__] damage you know
what I mean you know that awesome
feeling you get you
know if before you go to work you make
the bed and you come home and the bed's
made you know that [__] feeling or
maybe the night before you did all the
dishes and you wake up to make breakfast
and there's no dishes from the night
before that that that ahead of the game
feeling you know or at least I'm even
you know what I mean like I don't got to
start my day doing yesterday [__]
plus whatever the [__] hits me today um
that's what it's like to be on January
1st to actually be in shape and I don't
think I've I've done that since my 20s
so
um I'm really going to try and uh it
always helps me to announce it on the
podcast that I'm going to [__] do it
because I know you guys will [__] you
guys are going to check in on me and
you're going to give me [__] when I you
know if I'm not talking about it you
know I'm not doing well and God knows
you guys like to be mean but I probably
deserve it after what a [__] I was to
that lady last night I wasn't even a
[__] it's just the fact that she's a
woman and you're just supposed you know
you're just supposed to let them win be
like oh wow wow yeah you you you and you
yeah that's exactly what the joke was
about it was all about you all of you
why not talk about all of you you're so
interesting please tell me another story
about your dumb day and what you said
and oh my God what you were like so I
said this and then she said that and
then I was
like ladies how do you not see the pain
in your man's face when you're doing
that you know what I mean I see the pain
in my wife's face when I try to talk to
her about a game n there was [__] two
minutes left right Patriots are getting
killed on defense right we get the ball
back Tom Brady throws the ball giant guy
grabs and he [__] lands on his
stomach knocks his wind out and by then
it's just [__] over she just starts
making fun of me really oh my god oh
that's amaz she doesn't give a [__] you
know but if I don't listen to her
[__] stories oh Jesus I'll forget
about it today it's a big
goddamn I don't know what it is um
anyways let's get to some of the reads
for this week
okay yeah bill it's fine it's absolutely
fine oh I'm doing the Comedy Jam
tonight all right with the
[__] the [__] text messages there
um let's read the text message oh was
that somebody else who saw the fs for
family yeah they saw the trailer people
are liking the trailer thank Christ all
right uh venue dear Billy
bigshot now that you've done the mother
of all venues with
MSG what non-traditional venue would you
like to play like something like the
Great Wall of China congrats on your
year go [__] yourself
um no there's still there's still a
bunch that I would love to play uh Royal
Albert Hall is on my bucket
list um
and then there's also there's a bunch of
theaters that I would still like to play
or continue playing there's the one on
out here in California in Long Beach The
Long Beach something or other where
Richard prior did his uh live and
concert um I already did a show at the
Palladium that's where he did live on
the Sunset Strip and I forget if the the
one that he performed at when he did is
here and now which I think was in uh New
Orleans I got to see if that one still
exists but I really uh I like doing
those old theaters I like doing them man
it's like going to Old ballparks you
hear all the people that were there like
last night when we were down the um The
Comedy Store this this just characters
just show up right dick Gregory's on
stage and then this other guy comes in
cuz he knew Dick Gregory he was the
publicist for
SOS there was this nightclub I said
before it became uh The Comedy Store and
uh you know when Frank Dean Sammy and
all them were down there he was just
naming all of these [__] names he he
said yeah he goes I first came here in
1950 so I'm immediately doing the math
going Jesus Christ if this guy was like
20 in 1950 that's 65 [__] years ago
he's
85 um he didn't look like he was in his
' 80s he actually looked great but
um so let's see what V you know Red
Rocks I performed there though but I I I
did Red Rocks when it was uh there was
some sort of Animation thing going on
after it so Wendy at the comic Comedy
Works uh got me the gig and we went out
there but it was cool to be at Red Rocks
but uh they weren't there for me they
were there for the [__] film so there
was a lot of chatter but
um a lot of the things on my bucket list
are venues that
um that either ban played in that I love
and had some live album there or
comedians that did uh a special there so
I told you when I was in hammertown
there up in [__] uh Toronto Ontario I
mean in Ontario not Toronto
um that just kept calling it hammertown
I can't even remember the name of the
town but it's south of Toronto I didn't
realize I performed until after I was
there I performed at the theater where
Bill Cosby did Bill Cosby himself um
arguably the greatest special of all
time you know now what he did afterwards
I don't want to get involved in
that um so that was cool
um I did uh yeah that's a great question
I don't know what I I just want to keep
uh going I like going to venues that
I've never been to you know what I
really enjoyed this year is when I was
doing the Tour of California going to
Reno and Bakersfield and uh Fresno and
they were along the old school highways
where people were psyched like the
highway went right down Main Street so
they would have some big fancy sign you
know Reno biggest little town in uh you
know the west Fresno you know whatever
the [__] their slogan is you know they
would always have like town and then
some sort of slogan Bakersfield like hey
stop and stay a while you know some
corny [__] but um I really like that
Route 66 type of stuff and uh as far as
Europe goes that's to me is all about
World War 2 World War
I um those you
know those types of places but as far as
performing I don't know enough about
Europe and that type of thing uh I did
look up you know ACDC where they
recorded uh If You Want Blood their live
album that was a place I believe it was
in Glasgow or uh Edinburgh I want to say
Glasgow but uh the venue doesn't exist
anymore so um yeah so that I would say
that I get a big charge out of Music
place I'm a you know total nerd when it
comes to that [__] and uh I remember
when I was in England London uh a couple
years ago accidentally coming upon that
Ronnie Scots and I saw Jeff Beck have
one of the great
[__] was him Vinnie Kuda and that
chick on Bas and they just were [__]
unbelievable like Jimmy pige was in the
crowd you know sinking down in his seat
like oh yeah I stole that riff I
remember stealing that one from him
nicking it I believe as they call it so
yeah there's still plenty um left and um
the MSG for me was not as much as it was
a high water Market wasn't like this you
know and now I just slide down the back
nine for me it was uh it just felt more
like an honor to be there and it was
mine for an hour and a half and then you
know the second you leave somebody
else's name was on the Marquee it's like
wow I got to do that um but I got to
tell you I had just as much fun
uh [__] around with the new stuff you
know it's hard to describe unless you're
a comedian the excitement of new stuff
like oh I get to say new [__] I have to
keep saying this stuff and trying to
figure out how to make this [__] new
again tonight um
so anyways so yeah I would say a royal
Alber Hall is like the next one I'm
really thinking about but there's no way
there isn't something in Ireland or
something in Scotland or uh Finland
Norway I mean I think I'm doing a tour
of the
uh the [__] um Eastern Europe
be crazy to play a venue that like
[__] like Hitler or Stalin or melini
one of those fascist one I guess Stalin
wasn't a fascist but one of those
[__] maniacs gave his speech and you
know it still
exists you know [__] nuts right I
don't know all right bacing hey
Bill uh bacon Bill I'm thinking about
surprising my girlfriend and her family
by bringing over a homemade pie for
Thanksgiving all right dude I got got
you I'm going to make two pies because
one isn't enough I'm thinking about
apple and pumpkin also because also
please know that apple capitalizes
apple as if there's no such thing as
fruit oh the Apple company anyways I
know uh from previous years that you're
killing it in the kitchen oh thank you
before I call my mom and her two and get
her two cents uh from you can I get some
pointers some basic dues and
don'ts uh when getting into it should I
avoid either
apple the fruit uh or pumpkin thanks um
pumpkin pie is an easy recipe apple pies
work as far as the filling but it's also
[__] you know it's apples and cinnamon
man I mean come
on um I'll give you the biggest like the
filling is is easy all right the the
thing that scares and intimidates people
is doing the uh oh my God guys do I I
have to make a [__] pie crust making
video I'll [__] do it I'll put on the
apron I'll put on the apron in a silly
hat you want do I'll do that for you for
[__] Thanksgiving how about that I
will make a [__] pie
video um pie crust video uh but if
you're going to do it right now uh cuz I
won't get the video up in time I will I
will show you uh I'll try to walk you
through it all
right so the recip recipe that I use
it's two cups of allpurpose flour the
kinds that people say you know you're
going to die if you eat it that's what
you want with the pie you don't want to
go any lowfat you don't want to go wheat
you don't want to do any of that [__]
stinky feet Seattle thing up with it all
right you want to go Midwest Chicago
heart attack all right you're making a
pie you want to be healthy go have a
[__] salad that's not what we're
doing here that's not what stop your
crying and get out of my kitchen
right you know it's funny this roofers
fixing something on my [__] roof
that's never going to be fixed and they
probably just heard me yell that now
stop your crying and get out of my
kitchen you know that's how rumors start
I know that guy that guy tells jokes
yeah he's [__] verbally abusive to
his wife um anyway so what you want to
do is you h two cups of flour okay and
you get yourself a
sifter right and there's always a little
bit of salt go easy on the salt like an
eighth of a teaspoon so what I do is I
take the cup of [__] flour I pour it
into the sifter and the sifter is
sitting in the bowl that you're going to
sift into don't just pour it into the
sifter it's going to end up on your
counter you don't want that right so you
pour in one cup then you put in your
salt then you put your next cup over it
then you sit
it right it comes [__] out then uh
then you add your short in right I use a
stick of butter sorry you want it to be
cold so it's not too [__] mushy
uh take it out of the fridge you just
cut it up in like you know eighth of an
inch slices you put it in there and then
with your little [__] thing that you
hit see this is why I'm going have to do
a video you just you want to cover it
right and then you put your shortening
in and then cover that you want it to be
all like uh like you're making a [__]
meatball you want to get the breadcrumbs
all over except it's the flour and then
when you do that you just lightly tap
all the way
around you know you're letting that
shortening start kind of get into it
then you go a little harder a little
harder gets a little mealy once it's a
little mealy you start adding your water
I got to make a
video I got to make a video and I can
also show you how much you can [__] up a
crust and still save it and uh uh you
know what I got to do it I'll actually
do that but as far listen man pumpkin
pie is great but if you want to knock
people on their ass you got to make an
apple pie and I'd get three different
types of apples uh throw a granny smith
in there so you got a bitter thing and
then something else for a little sweeter
taste you you know little surf and turf
going on in there and uh you just make
sure you use enough cinnamon you know
what I mean I use about a half a healthy
half uh
teaspoon what has happened to me I'm
literally just sitting here talking
about this [__] like I'm about like it's
this is a
[__] game plan to win the [__]
football game tonight
um all right so anyways holiday wedding
uh Billy
Bells my friend from college is getting
married uh this Sunday after
Christmas ah Jesus what a stupid time to
do that was it CU everybody's in your
hometown he goes is there a worst time
for a wedding no can you believe that
it's in Upstate New York of course I can
if he's going to be a [__] he's going to
go all the way with it I'm sure it'd be
fun once I got there but I'm thinking
about skipping the circumstances are
grounds for not going right absolutely
they are [__] that [__] that you know
what I mean I always think that when
people do [__] like that anyways it
means one of two things they're kind of
hoping most people won't show up or two
they don't have enough money to throw a
good wedding anyway so all that great
food you're going to walk away from that
to go up
there and [__] eat hamburger
helper you know standing out on the
stage eating on the [__] Dance Floor
eating a stum C break Good Times come
on and you know one of your friends is
going to cancel last second that agreed
to go and you're going to [__] show
up there
wooo there's some [__] food being served
right here now some [__] shitty food
that's going to come out your ass yeah
[__]
that [__] that and he can never give you
[__] all you got to do for the rest of
your life when he gives you [__] or she
gives you [__] or whatever about not
going just you just you don't you're
sitting at the bar and they [__] your
[__] you don't you just keep looking
straight ahead and you just put throw
your hands out and you just go you got
married on the Sunday after
Christmas who does that that's it and as
they try to defend it you just talk over
married at the Sunday after Christmas
when the
Sunday after
Christmas it's almost like you didn't
want me to be
there huh if you get get divorced when
are you going to get married this time
[__] New Year's Day the [__] out of
here what do you think you're better
than Santa Claus you're better than the
baby Jesus huh you think you're better
than the prime rib my mother makes on
Christmas day you
[__] where the [__] do you get a
Upstate New York how dare you I'm going
to be that [__] person driving in a
station
wagon [__]
Sunday after CH get the [__] this is
like my time
off this is my time off this is my time
okay going to go to a Goddamn
wedding oh that just reeks of like my
friend got ordained as a [__]
preacher he's going to go up there in
his [__] street
clothes oh yeah I bet they're getting
married in like the basement of a
[__] holiday in and the ceremony's
going to be going and like the door to
the function room is still going to be
open and people going to be randomly
walking by looking at it you know they
got to keep the door open because
there's no bathroom in the function room
so you got to walk out oh that's a [__]
show Jesus Christ dude that's like uh
that's like a sales meeting you don't
want to go to well you know what I've
convinced myself that I wouldn't go I
don't know what you're thinking but um I
wouldn't go that's totally grounds for
skipping a wedding alone is grounds for
skipping who the [__] wants to go to
that unless you're still in your 20s and
then you know then it's good time you
want to go to a wedding single right go
there maybe bang somebody right have a
good time you don't to go there you know
if you're not married then eventually
she's going to look go when are we going
to do
this well you think of just [__]
running doing a running jump right off
the balcony all right sleep
trouble sleep trouble all right uh hey
Bill I just started traveling for work
and getting a good night and getting a
good night's sleep is brutal yes it is
I'm not trying ambian or increasing my
alcohol intake how do you deal with all
the travel uh alcohol uh do you use uh
one of those stupid neck pillows nope
Hotel Beds aren't bad if I do sleep well
I end up waking up feeling comos which
leads me to being more tired cuz those
beds are huge and soft and I don't want
to get out of bed you're also making up
for the sleep that you didn't get on
other nights which you can't really do
you know there's that weird thing that
if like say you know you got 6 hours one
night and then 10 hours the next night
so you
got you know it averages out to 8 hours
it still doesn't work that way for some
reason um you can't retroactively like
when you miss out on whatever it is you
need some people only need six some
people just need four but if you need
like whatever the [__] you need I'm
saying if you come up short you can't
just sleep extra one day and then even
it off it usually takes like a week like
I've been [__] sleeping this whole
week um falling asleep like an old
person so um but anyways let me continue
um and I don't want to get out of the
bed it h it hasn't happened yet but I
can see it's slowly turning me into a
grouchy [__] how do you do it were
you a cheery fellow before hitting the
road thanks for the free laughs
um how do I do it I'm German Irish
that's how I do it um we're not in touch
with our feelings so even if I am tired
I'm just naturally trained to BL lock it
out and I just get up and um and I go
but however every once in a while when I
do make a conscious
effort to think about slowing down and
relaxing and not having something to
achieve every [__] day be a picking
up dry cleaning or writing a new
joke um I suddenly become aware of how
tired I am so um what I would do yet is
not not uh not use any of the
drugs and I also wouldn't [__] with
alcohol I wouldn't do that either what I
would do is work out in the
morning and then go to your job whatever
it is that you do and then at night
because you were working all day and you
worked out you'll actually go to sleep
if you just get into the good habits out
there it's not that bad but um I don't
know biggest thing that I found is is
food food is difficult and uh if you're
doing like a bunch of one nighters if
you're like a traveling salesman kind of
[__] thing selling your Widgets or
whatever that's when it gets hard
because you spend your day traveling and
then you arrive at the hotel you're
[__] hungry but you got to go to your
gig so you usually end up you know
you're like yeah you guys got have
anything healthy like we got an
Applebees oh yeah do they deliver they
yeah they sure don't they sure
don't nodding yes they sure
don't you should shake your head no
can I get what I need you sure can't not
in this
town so then you then they always have
like [__] menus and they're always
going to give you some Chinese food
which is just is going to be UNF [__]
believable or absolutely horrific
depending on uh you know it has nothing
to do with where you're at every [__]
town in the United States has Chinese
food I believe and and every town has a
Chinese family that moved there right
for the most part or at least within two
towns there's a Chinese family that
moved there and they will make that
[__] food now whether or not there
people from China that know how to cook
that's the [__]
rub you know if you never know you never
know that I've been in the middle of
[__]
Kansas and I got some of the best sushi
I've ever had Japanese family middle of
[__] Kansas is like how did you end
up out here
this is unbeliev I I most of the white
people I know didn't end up out here how
did you from Japan end up in oy
[__]
Kansas oh speaking of bucket list man I
have like a bunch of college basketball
games I want to go to I want to go to
Kentucky I've always been a Kansas fan I
don't know
why I want to go to their their facility
I want to go to a Duke Carolina
game at Carol Ina and at
Duke
um I've been to
UCLA who else is a big basketball
program Georgetown Syracuse you know the
red men St John's redond whatever the
[__] they called now the Red Storm I
grew up on Big East basketball but uh I
used to love watching all of that [__]
so I've been to Indiana I told you guys
I went to Indiana University uh
University basketball game when Bobby
Knight was still on the team I I was I
could not [__] believe the level with
which that guy was screaming at his
players was
insane coming all the way out his
[__] head just
snapping as a point like they let up an
easy bucket and the point guard was
bringing it up to court and the [__]
guy I swear to God he walked like 10
feet out into the court everybody was
just like intimidated by him I just it
just annoyed me I wanted to see like
somebody stand up to him you know give
the guy a nice verbal [__] slap U but
it never happened
that guy classic example ego completely
out of [__] control
um when he started buying into being
Bobby Knight and he started doing those
I'm going to be Bobby Knight you know
what is what is a game face I never
understood that and he starts mugging to
the camera or when he goes uh you know I
hope when my credits bury me they bury
me face down so they can kiss my ass I
was like oh God shut up have another
drink um did I just make make fun of
Bobby Knight what what the [__] is wrong
with me um yeah so I'm doing the goddamn
Comedy Jam tonight at the uh let believe
believe it's The Lyric Theater on uh
LaBrea and um looking forward to doing
that I got yeah I don't want to tell you
guys I got nothing else I can't even do
a [__] hour that's That's how little
I've been doing this week I got caught
up on py
blinders py blinders I don't know
nothing about no
robway um pey blinders with subtitles uh
I'm up to the uh first episode of season
2 so I'm going to blow through that this
week and then my wife is watching
bloodline I believe that's the name of
it with uh Norbert Leo Butts who I did a
failed pilot with a long time ago and uh
he's a [__] great guy and I keep
walking in there and he's absolutely
crushing every scene and uh so I I got
to watch it out of solidarity
um we actually a long time ago did a
[__] pilot did I ever tell you guys
this [__] story we did a pilot and
they wanted
edgy all right I thought I told you guys
this one Whatever who gives a [__]
um they wanted edgy okay it was you know
and they were letting us go really
far and the
uh the pilot name was playing
chicken was the name of this pilot and
the premise was was
um me and Norbert were brothers he was
Republican and I was Democrat and
norbert's character was paralyzed from
the waist
down and he was paralyzed because he was
playing chicken on a [__] jet ski and
neither person turned away and he got
paralyzed so that's what's the name of
it so that's already the [__] premise
so he was like over the top [__]
homeless people and all that [__] so
anyway so we're doing
you know whatever they write this edgy
[__]
pilot and uh writers were about ready to
do the [__] run through where all the
[__] major Network guys come down
it's basically you do it's basically
it's like a live
play all right let me just give you a
little backs basically what happens is
if you're on a sitcom you have the table
read on Monday right if it kills you go
upstairs and you do a bunch of blocking
in the fake living rooms and all that
which is basically I'm going to stand
over here when I do this you go through
the whole [__] thing if it bombs and
they know that they're going to rewrite
a lot of [__] you have a quick [__]
day like well we're going to get a new
script tonight and this will be you know
a little bit different so then Tuesday
comes around you [__] rehearse it you
still got your script in hand and then
you do a run through and it's just for
the uh the production company like the
whoever's you know making the thing so
it's that's friendly fire there you know
those are like the executive producers
and the people that wrote it the writers
and all that so they watch it and they
see what's working what isn't what needs
to be fixed what can stay the same what
they can add on to and then
Wednesday is the network run through and
that's when the people that can cancel
your [__] show show up and leave
their sense of humor at the [__] door
right so that's always a nerve-wracking
[__] day and you go out there and if
you do a couple lines they don't get
laughs you start getting in your head
like you're going to get fired you know
and as you're walking from one fake
living room to the fake bar or coffee
house that you hang out the only sound
you hear is the shoes of the [__]
Executives walking over to the next
[__] the next scene so anyway so
we're doing this [__] pilot and the
opening scene is we're sitting there at
some ice cream place eating ice cream
and this homeless guy whatever we're
having our back and forth and this
homeless guy comes up and ask for money
so I of course being the liberal go to
give some money and norbert's character
being the conservative guy you know
basically tells the guy to [__] off so
everybody's loving it he actually I
remember flicked ice cream at
him um oh he decided he was going to do
that during the [__] run through cuz
we weren't going to do it all day long
flicking ice cream and it be a [__]
mess so he just kept miming flicking the
ice cream that's what it was so anyways
people are digging the pilot you know
the producers and all the writers are
all thinking it's funny they're laugh it
up we do the regular run through it's
going great so now we got the network
run through but the next day and it just
so happens that during that week or
whatever Don
Imus said The Nappy Headed Hoes [__]
comment and for whatever reason all hell
[__] breaks loose like you know
Hitler's back and
um it becomes this big [__] lightning
rod thing that allows a bunch of people
who don't you know want to increase the
fines with the FCC and all this [__] all
basically what this one guy said on the
radio trickles all the way down to our
pilot that has these [__] suits
nervous you know just in general about
we better watch our step because Don
Imus I don't know what lost some
advertising money so they're in that
[__] head space and they come down to
our show where we got a half paralyzed
guy you know and the opening scene we're
doing the scene it's getting zero laughs
and I remember the homeless guy walked
out and they even gasped at that because
they really made him look homeless he
was really
dirty Norbit goes all the jokes are
bombing and he goes and turns around and
flips this [__] globa ice cream and
hits the actor right in the face and
they
gasped and no La I mean I thought it was
going to kill we thought it was the
funniest [__] ever they there wasn't a
[__] they they just G gasped and then
it ended right and then just the sound
of their shoes just
shuffling all the way down to the other
side of the set for the next [__]
scene and it dude it was the worst run
through I've ever been and I'm talking
there was Zero laughs it was dead
[__]
silence and I just remember walking by
this one actress she delivered her line
and it got nothing and she walked by
looking at me like what the [__] is
happening and I almost bursted out
laughing because for actors it's like
[__] I'm going to get fired and I'm
going to be unemployed again for a
comedian I can still I'm not I'm not
unemployed I can just go back to doing
shows the fact that I'm on this thing is
is gravy so the look on her face was
just I mean I don't want her to be out
of work but it was just funny to me so
the more it was bombing the the harder I
committed to what I was doing just
because if you're going to bomb you
might as well just [__] do the triple
Lindy so I was just going bigger and it
just was just dead [__]
silence so the run through ends I mean
you can hear a [__] pin drop and it
was to the point I was like dude I don't
think they're going to shoot this
[__] thing
so me and Norbert went back to the hotel
we go right to the bar and we just start
laughing going I'm getting fired he's
going no I'm getting fired and we had
like a bet who's going to get fired it's
like somebody's going down for that it's
like you know like LSU loses three in a
row somebody's got to pay the price
somebody's getting [__]
fired so
um they ended up uh showing up and they
talked to both of us individually in the
uh in our hotel
rooms I remember the guy that directed
the thing he came walking into my room
and just sat down on my bed and started
eating the peanuts my peanuts without
asking and I was most arrogant thing I'd
ever seen in my life and I was just
sitting there going
like it still bugs me to this day I
didn't say anything to that guy um but
anyways so they [__]
uh so they ended up toning this whole
[__] thing
down right they go look we're not going
to we're not going to get rid of you
guys uh was the wrong tone but blah blah
blah and then what ended up happening
was they [__] dialed it back like 40%
really took all the balls out of it
um and then you know a few days later we
shot the pilot from a live studio
audience and it actually killed it went
great but it didn't end up getting
picked up and uh and that's my uh that's
my uh story about bombing sorry guys I
had I had to go in the well there man I
ran out of [__] stories to tell tell
you for this week all I know is that the
bills are playing the Patriots tonight
in Gillette Stadium Anything Can Happen
um they just don't have a quarterback
they got a great defense though so we'll
see what happens uh I don't think the
Patriots losing one game is the worst
[__] thing I think it's actually
better man it it makes people focus on
somebody else so uh you know worst case
scenario we're 9 and one I'm on vacation
you know I'm having a good time here so
uh that is it I'll talk to you guys on
Thanksgiving um I'll try to make a a pie
crust video I'm going to do that [__]
why not I said I was going to do it
right that'll be me giving back giving
thanks to you guys listen than to the
podcast um I'm doing and listen to The
Joe Rogan uh podcast uh Joe Rogan
Experience I'm going to be doing that
tomorrow
um and uh I think that's it Happy
Thanksgiving to everybody if you're
traveling you don't have time to listen
to this podcast I don't get a chance to
say it Happy Thanksgiving thank you to
everybody that's coming out to my show
uh over the years from the bottom of my
heart I really appreciate it and uh
that's it go [__] yourselves and I'll
check it on you on
[Music]
Thursday
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast NFL Edition
uh for what preview week week number 12
week number 12 can it be oh my god dude
this where's the time going this was a
blink of an eye um when are people going
to get used to the time going by fast
Paul I think it's an age thing I think
it's when when are you g to get used to
it I think because I have to listen to
somebody every [__] year agoo can you
believe the Summer's over can you
believe it Paul I mean God it just feels
just like yesterday we would taking the
[__] bathing suits out of the [__]
attic you look
or or the people that take it too far
the people that go I know I know I know
it's crazy and the kids are getting so
big what happened what happened it's
like I turned around and all of a sudden
she's divorced in 26 sucking [__] behind
her Dunkin'
Donuts
or then the or then the over uh over
emotional ones who go I know and then
the kids leave I can't I can't that's
the hardest
part oh I'm an old dad so I always get
this so I tell you you know they go up
fast you better you know make sure you
don't [__] I go I know I know I know
and they're like no I'm telling you it's
like dude I get it I get it you weren't
there you weren't there stop projecting
your awful job as a dad onto me no
matter what they it's going to fly by
everything [__] flies by just shut up
about it flying by here's what they
should say I wasn't
there I
was let me tell you something I wasn't
there well it was time to learn a bite
right a bike I missed
it uh all right guys my kid still can't
swim okay that hurts
[Laughter]
me you know tell the alphabet their
neighbor I wasn't there Paul I missed
their first steps I missed their first
steps oh oh [__] oh I needed to laugh I
needed to laugh Paulie's having a bad
one this week dude usually usually I'm
I'm I'm dude I'm having a I'm having one
Paulie needs a glass of red wine and to
put his feet up on Thanksgiving and be
grateful for his life and everything
because Paul had a rough one um okay all
right well you
know Bill nothing a little nothing a
little Cabernet savan can't handle there
you go that's right why deal with what's
making you sad when you can
medicate is is a gambling thing I love
Paul I love the [__] oh Jesus Christ
I love the expert Gambler you know who
he comes on like I've won so much that
now I'm gonna pay it forward and I if
you pay me I'm gonna pick you winners
it's just like wait a minute you're so
good at gambling that you're gonna stop
and help me out get the [__] out of here
you lost your ass you realized you can't
beat the [__] book so now you're
trying to [__] you know have me go
make your bets well I pay you 20 bucks
to lose right yeah I saw this one guy he
was he said he had his hair slick back
black slick back and he had glasses on
and his sweater and he goes don't tell
me about all the games you lost and then
you just talk about the two you won I'm
here to win dude it was but ridiculous
if you saw his if you saw what he was
wearing it was almost like he went to a
costume place and the costume said
professional Gambler
outfit um all right I'm gonna teach you
things that the bookie does not want you
to know if the quarterback's got a flu I
know um uh all right guys this dude I
was just out in Vegas I'm not goingon to
name the Cino but they got this new
[__] rule out there on
Blackjack on black Jack if the dealer
hits 22 it's a push that's ridiculous
and that's [__] unamerican I got
another one for you I went to Dunkin
Donuts dunk and donuts you can't get
them at a grocery store even though you
kind of can now um I go in there to get
a dozen [__] munchkins and they go I
can't do that they only come in 10 I'm
like yeah let me guess it's the same
[__] price right I didn't say that
but that's you know I said it nicer than
that cuz the lady behind the register
she's like yeah I don't I don't know
it's like my first well why do you think
that is cuz the last person [__] quit
CU they're trying to that's the skim
Paul that's the skim I mean dude not
you're 100% right not getting a dozen
donuts at Dunkin Donuts is not no the
munchkins I can only give you 10 I can
only oh you had did the price go down by
two munchkins is this another [__]
scam you figured out this quarter to
make a little bit more money dude I
swear to God Paul like the Geniuses they
have us all yelling at each other the
biggest [__] welfare recipients in
this [__] country are the [__]
[__] at the top they take all the
[__] money they don't pay any taxes
and then they blame broke people that
have no money no power and make no
decisions they have politicians in their
pockets Paul I'm on a rant
here uh oh dude I can't wait I can't
wait to talk about coaches that's one
thing that's on the agenda today I want
my coach look like he [__] played
football like he lined up and he scared
people like that new Raiders coach
that's a [__] coach
I don't want the coach to look like
somebody I cheated off of in [__]
math class that's just me Paul that's
just who I am I want to be afraid of my
coach I don't want my coach to look like
a slease ball either I don't want a
snake either I want booze on his breath
yeah a little overweight little gullet
you know um I don't want a head case
either but I like a nice slob if a guy's
gonna be a slob I like a nice slob yeah
he just eats bad food he eats bad food
but means well yeah means yeah yeah I
don't want a fat cokehead I want a guys
getting Grand Slam breakfast I'll tell
you best happy looking
slob Wade
Phillips what Wade Phillips was Phillips
nice guy W Phillips coaches a football
game he looks like he's holding his
wife's purse and he doesn't care figured
out loves his wife I could tell just by
watching could tell he's a
romantic I could tell just by watching
him fail on that fourth and three his
reaction he loves his wife and you know
what he did after he failed on that
fourth down P he immediately put it in
perspective you know in the bigger
picture that's right that's exactly
right um I love my wife I got a nice
house Jerry Jones can control me that's
what he wants that's why the Cowboys
will never
win Jerry Jones is their problem Jerry
Jones is The Nightmare Before Christmas
in Dallas Jerry Jones is Dracula dude
he's Dracula he's not he sleeps in a
[__] coffin let me tell you something
it's the biggest coffin in all the NFL
we got the biggest football we got the
biggest [__] the biggest [__]
bathroom at our [__] Stadium we got
the biggest hole in the roof so Jesus
can watch too my wife designed it my
wife put that remember he said my wife
did the chandelier she did it this ain't
me I gotta give her all the credit
remember the credit I wouldn't give
Jimmy Johnson I'm now giving him a
wh I rode here today on a
horse get a [__] GM and shut up
[__] wax faac son of a [__] oh [__]
this has nothing to do with Jerry Jones
has to do with the fact I went one and
three last week Paul because [__]
whoever the [__] he is can't kick a
goddamn [__] field goal Paul I'm I'm
slipping away I'm going into the deep
water bill you went two and two
bill I mean you wrong every week you
went two and two and I went two and two
hey Paul if you know if I want to get
insulted I would just go talk to my wife
all right I don't need to listen to you
tell me that I'm wrong also we w we both
went two and two and you I went one no I
didn't yeah yeah you went I don't know I
I don't know uh anyway let's get into
[__] Seattle goddamn [__] game
this is what I hate about gambling Paul
is I I'm literally [__] mad about an
a an NFC West game my team was off I
should have had my feet
up you know having a having a SAS
Barilla Paul what am I doing what's a
SAS what am I doing huh I'm [__]
losing my [__] about the [__]
Seahawks and the Rams I don't give a
[__] about either one of those teams
dude when I lose a heartbreaker I just
do I you know I pull a weight Phillips I
go get the next one that's not true Paul
you text in caps no only Giants only
when my team
does when these guys go down I hurt I
get hurt I hurt me okay I don't know
I've gotten a lot of
[__] no you what what are they doing
what are they doing oh you know who I
ran into the other day I ran I went to
uh oh I'm gonna do a little promo here
uh Leo on Netflix starring Adam Sandler
old freckles does a little voice in that
and uh when I was at the premiere
[__] great movie dude really funny
bunch of jokes from for adults and the
my kids loved it too um I ran to uh Nick
taturo and I was like oh my god dude I
go you during baseball season when the
Yankees are messing up it's my favorite
it's like that guy's like such a real
fan I just love when I don't even know
the Yankees are playing and all of a
sudden he'll just send out a text all
caps that just says what are they
doing and I'm like all right evidently
the Yankees are playing ton night and
they were up and now now they're they're
not up like that guy gives a [__] about
game 47 of the regular of of the
whatever the [__] you call B what's
baseball's regular season called the
season the SE yeah 162 games dude and
Yan I will say this I will say this I
hate to say this I mean it's going to be
a tough thing for me to say on this
show
look look look dude I gotta here's the
thing with me here's the thing with me
dude I gotta call it how I see it I
gotta call the truth Red Sox fans at on
a baseball level are I mean that's like
a like Red Sox with baseball is
something your fans are are [__] know
everything [__] it I mean on a real but
I will say Yankee fans too not maybe as
much as you guys Yankee fans and Red Sox
fans this is where you buy back the
compliment no no no we're right there no
because I was gonna say us because I was
gonna say Yankee fan a real Yankee fan
will call up the fan I heard it dude we
were on game 11 last year and he called
up and he goes dude I just see it man we
don't have it now granted he was right
but he's talking about our infield and
it's week 11 and he had a [__] whole
scream at them going it's it's it's I
mean it's game 11 uh you guys are like
that too with the Red Sox dude I I give
it to July um but dude did you see the
video so what just happened there you
started to compliment us and then you
just talked about some Yankee guy
calling it by game 11 and then you just
walked away from it it was like I saw
the gift I was reaching for the gift bag
and then you just [__] sort of
moonwalked out I was basically saying I
was basically saying you guys are
probably the best baseball town and I
just didn't have it fully in my heart to
Let It Go
I think that that's what happened honest
and then I just went Yan you fans care
too um dude did you see was that the NFL
pretending that they support the troops
but they actually get paid like it's a
commercial hey hey ma'
I come on you know my birthday's
Veterans Day and my wife always gets me
the Veterans Day act like you served
look at this I did you know you know my
birthday's Veterans Day so what do I got
to thank you for your service [__]
being born on Veterans Day you weren
even you weren't even the [__] Cub
Scouts I like the Veterans Day apparel
you know I like to get everything
Veterans Day because it was my birthday
that's all a gift it was a gift okay but
you started in on with me with like I
wasn't supporting the troops no no I
thought you which is what has led to
bankrupting this [__] country you
can't criticize the coaches or that
means you don't who doesn't support the
[__]
troops yeah I mean if you don't it's the
dumbest thing ever so then you can't
question where they put him and then you
watch the coffers of the whole [__]
country go like this and then they blame
Ty Paul I'm on a ran again dude you know
what is Paul I'm just gearing up for
another election where my two choices
are going to be two scile [__] 90y
olds like this is the best can I get a
40-year old I I know actually gonna have
to live with his
decisions dude I said that on stage I go
can we get a 36 year old that looks like
James Bond just once I go if you get
that guy I don't give a [__] about his
policies I want a full head of hair
slick back nice
like7 yeah know yeah and then [__] go
out there to Mon Mon Carlo pull you know
go throw some dice I don't give a [__]
you make me you you look good you make
me feel good I don't want two [__]
old guys bil he pulls up in a Lambo the
[__] thing comes up he comes out with
a cocktail he starts pointing like no no
the door comes up and a secret service
guy gets out first that was sitting in
his lap and then he gets
out oh dude did you see I didn't know
this but apparently the Diamondbacks who
just lost the World Series dude this was
[__] brutal talk about a relation by
the [__] Rangers but talk about a
relationship being over with friends I
would imagine dude apparently the
Diamondbacks bring in a pitcher that was
like struggling through the playoffs and
he came out of the [__] thing and he
starts jogging in and they showed the
the and I guess this is the last game
like or something when it was really
close and they showed the catcher and
the catcher watching him jog in and the
catcher just
goes dude like it was basically like
you're bringing that [__] guy in to
lose you never know his girlfriend
probably said something before the game
going like the good the good thing is if
you lose tonight then we can go on that
stay vacation and he's probably thinking
like I this is what I dreamed about as a
kid and then people
like Paul never underestimate my ability
to blame
women um all right guys this is uh week
12 of the you see when George W bush got
a standing ovation at the Rangers game
there's a guy who bankrupted the
country talk about a guy that got a pass
dude that guy came out on Kimmel and
everybody was clapping like he was I
remember when people [__] hate I mean
that's unbelievable dude his playing the
saxophone like like [__] stupid Bill
Clinton his thing he played the
saxophone on Areno and then he just gets
he's cool pass he's the he was the guy
who did the final nail in the coffin to
deregulate the banks that set up 2008
George W bush [__] threw a heater
right after 9/11 he can do no wrong
that's
it yeah I mean you gotta give it up as a
pressure pitch dude Yankee Stadium I
mean a tough pitch with a [__] vest
on they said he had a vest on d i thing
was that thing was they said he talked
about it for like 15 years after he
still talks about it her yeah you know
you what else is he gonna talk about
yeah his painting um his policies where
he goes oops Yeah I guess I was wrong on
that one I mean talk about [__]
brutal
Coalition of the Willing
pull all right guys it's the uh week 12
preview and uh I believe Andrew you can
check but I believe we both went two and
two last week it's the bed MGM app
everybody all you got to do is download
the bmgm app put $10 in and then all you
have to do is uh you do a $10 bet you
get up to $200 regardless of the outcome
of your bet there you go you have a lot
of fun with us came close to another
special Bill we came close to another
special dude you know what kills me is
Mahomes threw to Kelce in the beginning
of the like the second touchdown so by
the second quarter two out of three
things happened [__] Jaylen Herz
throws a bomb to this guy 41 yard
completion tackled on the one yard line
and then he runs it in did they review
it did they was he close to the
touchdown or no they didn't review it
the guy called it on the field and he he
got it right you know what I [__]
hate about that Paul can they ever have
the angle right like oh that's a first
down and I'm [__] looking at it like
this it's like what does it take they
literally have a [__] camera on the
[__] marker and it still looks a
little [__] off that's that that's
that viig that's their juice that's
their juice yeah um all right well this
week is week number 12 and I believe I
have the first pick this week Paul I
believe you do too and oh this is
Thanksgiving football week oh Paul can
you believe it's Thanksgiving already
the kids get so
big can you believe for the price of 12
munchkins you get
10 [__] Joe burrow out for the year
PA would you like to upgrade and get a
straw these are going to be the new
scams by the way we don't wash our
glasses would you like to upgrade and
get a
straw you know what Paul Paul's looking
Paul's looking early my wife is like
texting me it's like you know what it's
Thanksgiving
dude all right hey Paul in their world
it's always Thanksgiving it's never
worth it it's never worth it all right
here we go my first
I wanted to go see a movie today Paul
that's what I wanted to do we're not
doing that oh I wanted to see a movie
too I want to see
Thanksgiving oh yeah it's Thanksgiving
why wouldn't I go see it I love Quinton
Tarantino Tim Thanksgiving no I don't
think it's
Tarantino it's uh what did you just say
it's Eli Roth I believe I know but it's
his fake movie trailer that he put out
he did machete Yeah Tim Dylan's in it
that's right yeah Eli
Roth dude the way you just said Tim
Dylan is in it after you just read that
[__] text it it really annoyed me no
I'm what you just glanced over and you
had the [__] answer what do you mean
look at what it says private chat says
Eli Roth and it says Tim Dylan is in it
it's Jake The Snake helping us out oh no
but I saw Eli Roth in the interview and
I saw Tim's head I don't want to give it
away but anyway check it out I guess I
you believe Eli Roth already has another
movie coming out I mean where is the
time going remember how young he was
when he started I also want to see uh
waen Phoenix as
Napoleon yeah I'm getting tired of that
[__] dude man
what I don't know just when he [__]
started crying about the calf I was just
like dude crying about what calf muscle
or an animal no the animal he was
basically like talking about like um
when they take the calf from the mother
and then they get a stake out of it it
was like this vegan thing but he got
emotional and I was just like oh dude I
loved your performance and I didn't want
to go
there um he was like when you take the
CF from the mother you could hear them
crying out for their mother and he was
like I thought it was it almost like
sounded like he was talking about
children and he was talking about cows
and [__] and I was like all right man
well I
mean is he wrong I'm not saying I'm not
gonna have a steak but I'm just saying
you don't want to Paul you know what it
is the same way you don't want to know
where your gas comes from you don't want
to know where your steak comes from Paul
you don't want to know where that hoodie
came
from you any crying children seed that
together for 30 cents a
month oh man bill I don't know what to
do for my first pick oh I know what to
do just [__] let it rip look at a
game that [__] makes you
[__] I don't know what I was gonna
say the hair on top of your head stand
up that makes your [__] your your
beard get a little fuzzier how about
this Jake The Snake I'm off the Chargers
it's over ladies and gentlemen it's over
my God it's over they they finally when
Ace Rothstein finally walked away from
Sharon
Stone hey take your [__] money is
this what you
want all right how about this I was
gonna go I was gonna do something here
because of thanksgiv but I'm gonna flip
I'm gonna change it I'm gonna
take the Denver
Broncos I'm going to take the Denver
Broncos at home oh uh minus two and a
half sucks I thought it was one and a
half mine is I'm going still take it at
two and a half I'm you know what they've
won a few games in a row now and Russell
Wilson now has 19 touchdowns tied for
third in the NFL I like that kid
Sutton I'm gonna take the the the Denver
Broncos at home against the Browns who
have a backup quarterback I know they
have a good defense but I'm just going
to see if Denver can ride this out and
squeeze in there I like it all right I'm
G I'm gonna take the Philadelphia Eagles
minus three against the Buffalo Bills oh
I like the eagles with who's that coach
Crazy Eddie I'm crazy Eddie dude that's
the best one that's I'll be honest with
you dude that is probably one of I just
he he is completely emotionally unstable
and you know what I [__] I feel seen
as the kids say I [__] love that guy
do you I love that guy he annoys me you
you don't know what he's going to do
he's cries there in the anthem he nods
at the camera he's yelling at [__]
he's yelling at uh Chiefs fans I wish he
yelled at Mom's wife that would have
been perfect the two of them yeah [__]
you that would have been awesome oh if
he did that then I would have been a fan
forever that would have been WWE if the
two of them got going I love both of
them man [__] yeah me too I love
lunatics and I just believe in um Jaylen
herz's ability to extend the play Paul
you think you got him he runs he gets
the [__] first down or he runs around
enough where people get open I just feel
like the bills they won last week they
had a big and they just keep going and
now here we go now here we go and now
we're going to be what everybody thought
we were and and and they just keep every
they just keep tripping over their own
feet the Eagles minus three
Paul at home too that's a good pick all
right
man all right dude come on Paul pull the
trigger do it Paulie don't think about
it just
relax and squeeze you don't have the
balls
yeah all right uh oh this again oh hey
hey guess who said he's gonna kill
[Laughter]
himself
uh do I dare have the balls to do
this no I don't I'm gonna do you know
what I'm gonna it's too many point I
don't that's all right oh you gonna do
the the Cowboys no no I was looking at
the I was looking at the um the Texans
and uh dude I don't know who the Texans
are a really good team that are going to
make the playoffs and that's too [__]
close of a line I'll be honest with you
guys I'm not going into this week I'm
going into this week a little
wishy-washy here dude I'm not gonna lie
I don't like this Paul I know I know
this isn't like you I know this is
November this is verie time you know
what I gotta go Detroit Lions on
Thanksgiving I know it's seven and a
half I know I hate the half I hate the
half I lost it's a loss but here's the
thing here's the thing it's not the I
mean the half kills me but listen I
think the Lions want to really show out
on Thanksgiving because this is yeah I
would rather root for the [__] Lions
on Thanksgiving that's their day it's
not the Packers no it's not their day
and I think that why are they even there
I think that a 8-2 Lions team you know
this used to be their Super Bowl I think
they're G to go let's show everybody who
we really are everybody's G to be
watching it's probably one of the most
watched games in the of the year I'm
going to take them I do hate the half
yeah if you your wife doesn't put on the
Westminster dog show no she she knows
better uh we watched the dog show and
then I I I watch the game later although
I'm not gonna lie to you Paul I like the
dog show and for two years in a row me
and my lovely wife we picked the winner
you know many [__] dogs that is Paul
that's nice that's like hitting a three
team teas in a sport you don't even
watch the [__] do I know about
dogs um all right lion 7 I know they're
happy when you come home they're happy
to see you
yeah you know they make you feel like
you
matter unlike some of the people you
live
with dude I'm in such a stupid mood
anybody watching this I don't mean half
the [__] I'm saying I'm just being a
[__] I'm just goofing new boot
goofing all right what do you got Paul I
took lions in at seven and a half oh you
did I'm [__] running my Yap like a d
sh the half but I'm gonna take them
seven and a half hey Paul you know I
actually
yeah you know what the Texans do Paul
they cover what is it one and a half
oh yeah I'm gonna take the Texans I
believe in them I don't believe in the
Jaguars don't you shake your [__]
head at me Paul do I shake your head
when you make p shake it in a good way
relax I'm going all right defensive no
I'm shaking like he's got see that's so
then you don't know what the catcher of
the Diamond Backs was doing you don't
know what he was saying no when you see
I just misread you no when you see it
you know
oh you know Paul there's too many
[__] cameras you can't even have a
[__] moment you can't even have a
[__] moment somebody picks it up it's
how do the Astros not think they were
gonna get caught that's what amazes me
dude that's a bit that's a bit these
guys in Pro Sports they can do nothing
remember what's his name tried to bite a
sandwich he was hungry so he had like a
he just went like this and it was just
like the biggest meme he just was hungry
yeah I know if he just went out ate
it he would have been fine if he just
[__] ate it it would have been funny
if you try and hide it that's right it's
like being gay Paul if you're in the
closet people that like gay people like
he's totally gay they come at you like
[__] animals the second you come out
Paul it's like it's like you're a hero
it's like you were the one who dropped
the bombs yeah you ever notice that Paul
when are you going to come out you're
trying too hard with that [__] [__]
Brown uh vest you got on there on man a
what color is that it's uh
Brown I would debate that it's Brown
look look what color does it look you
know what it is Paul it's
depressing I know probably for a show it
probably is brown doesn't look good on
camera I mean it's designed to hide in
the [__]
Mojave yeah that's right L land Paul
yeah I should have went with a more
color that pops go ahead
it's my turn
again I just picked the Tex oh [__] I'm
sorry Look at me now I'm yapping all
right hey Paul look at us you
know all right so you got the Texans I
do have the Texans I have the Eagles and
I have the Texans and I feel pretty good
about that I got some East Coast people
I got some people down in Texas you
know I can't take that
game all right top city in Texas who do
you like I'm a big fan of Texas I like
Dallas Dallas is my favorite I'm a
Dallas guy Dallas is my favorite yeah
even though I'm not I'm big show off I
like watching people showing off I like
Dallas look at my wife big
titties you can stick your face in them
if you want to Andrew I'm sorry on shirt
on though shirt
on I I'm sorry Andrew you're gonna
probably have to edit dude I'm all over
the place this week dude I don't know
man I got me Paul you know when I went
out I got my own ranch right out side of
Dallas I got me a
douly ain't even for me either it's my
for my grandson my grand
nephew I let him just drive around he
ain't gonna hit nothing if he runs over
something we'll just [__] eat
it should I take the I'm G
take I'm gonna take the Raiders getting
nine I'm going to take the Raiders
getting nine against the Chiefs I think
the Chiefs win the game but you know
what the Raiders are coming off their
first loss under Antonio Pierce and
their home and I think the crowd's going
to be into it and I think it could be a
back door cover it's a divisional
rivalry too those games historically
close who do the Raiders have at
quarterback that's the problem that's
why I stayed away is Mad Max back I
don't know I don't know but they have
oconnell at quarterback I don't know
dude
oconnell listen not going to lie this is
uh this is uh Paulie's wishy-washy week
I don't know all right this is this is
where I get wishy-washy a Aiden okono no
disrespect this is where I get
wishy-washy Paul I'm thinking Packers I
don't want to do that to myself
beautiful wife two beautiful kids I
don't need to be [__] screaming about
a game on Thanksgiving you know [__]
that [__] that game then the
Ravens minus three and a half against
the Chargers I kind of like that I kind
of like the Browns Paul plus two and a
half I'm going to go you know what the
game's going to be
on out here by the way totally overrated
the [__] NFL package because the best
game is usually on regular TV anyway and
you get the best announcers I'm yeah I
don't watch football game I watch the
Giants and whatever game is on TV the
nation worst football Market ever Paul
New York City when I [__] live there
all I got was the boring ass Giants and
the shitty [__] Jets every that was
the one o'clock and then the four
o'clock and they [__] sucked
it [__] sucked but I'm a Giants fan
so I that's fine for me I'm just saying
Paul yeah it's a terrible [__]
Market okay it's UNF
fuckingcum was when I was in New York
was the [__] Yankees and whoever the
[__] they signed and watching them
steamroll the league that was sort of
something to watch all right I'm going
to take the Ravens mineus three and a
half against them San Diego Chargers
Paul you got to move out to Southern
California Paul they got strawberries
the size of your head the Ravens are
your Sharon Stone dude you just can't no
they're not I stayed away from these
[__] for
weeks um they turn the ball over I
learned that watching Inside the NFL by
the way did you see the the host of that
did you see that
[__] Medallion he hang had hanging
off his chest I was just I I'm off his
chain I mean I I wish I could get away
with that oh no I didn't see that it was
something else Paul
um we're at whatever Planet we're
settling next I feel like he had the
answer and and and like that that thing
hanging off his chain like somebody else
has it you stick it together and then
you just teleport out of here that's how
nice it
was I'm gonna take the Miami Dolphins to
beat the Jets by
10 oh man this is a week that's gonna
be you know what I loved about that I
love how you tried to have false
confidence on that pick
1,000% nothing was Faker nothing was
Faker than that confidence with that
pick um I'm gonna just you know what man
the Jets have their third string
quarterback I think it's nine and a half
somebody just wrote in nine and a half
nine and a half hey hey Paul hey hey
that could be the difference between
enjoying the stuffing and uh throwing it
against the wall dude it's at the Jets
too but they have just they're just bad
man they're anemic they can't move the
[__] ball so you get scared in the
first half cuz they have a good defense
but then they can't move the ball then
their defense gets tired and then those
Dolphins start running downhill even
though they don't have feet Tyreek Hill
Tyreek Hill and they they're healthy and
they you know I just think with the Jets
with a third string quarterback man I'm
just gonna take I'm just gonna take
Miami to to to win that game by a lot I
think the Jets season is over and I
think it'll allow Aaron roders to rest
and not have to [__] rush back with
an Achilles so there you go I'm gonna
take that [__] okay
Paul FY Dolphins minus 9 and a half in
the aluminum siding stadium that
is Met Life people trash in that Stadium
Paul I like it you know what I like
about that stadium looks like a football
stadium uh what they like there's not a
place to [__] wash your nuts every
[__] 10
feet um I got the Lions oh my god dude
I'm getting all these points I mean this
is [__] rough dude you're laying
points yeah I mean I'm just
I'm daring with you I'm daring the NFL
guys to give me a losing
week what did you go last week two and
two oh two and two a lose and week for
you we both went two and two Oh Billy
win some lose some some lose every
[__] week I'm four games under I've
two and two every week and I've had two
one in three weeks that's insane
actually possibly three that's actually
insane to do 12 weeks of that and be
that [__] even and barely know
anybody's name in the NFL cuz you
because you're [__] doing the right
thing Paul by the way playing with your
kids by the way why so fast Paul this
is this is the most injury season ever
for major players dude like like uh
Aaron Rodgers and now Joe burrow and
they uh Andrew Thomas uh the wide
receiver Mike Williams like all these
guys are just out for the year man it's
like I got a theory on that I don't
remember guys getting hurt I got a
theory on that what's the theory I just
want to be that guy in the sports oh you
know that guy you just sitting there
going like oh Jesus Christ I'll tell you
what it is I tell you what it is ever
you know what it is I'll tell you what
it is yeah they put too many pellets in
the astro turf look at look at it look
my buddy my buddy has the contract he
was telling me he said he said we're
done and the owner said no put more
down they caused cancer there's lead in
those
tires that's what it is they keep saying
that they're blowing out their knees
they're actually it's lead poisoning and
they're covering it up
yeah yeah or or the guy that goes like
this this is the funny guy I love this
guy the guy that goes no they knew he
was going to be hurt they knew they it's
like what they let him out there I think
he was already hurt he you know those he
no dude he was hurt in training camp you
could see it I anytime anytime there's a
quick trade you know what it was he was
banging the owner's daughter that's what
it
was he was he was hooking up with there
they told him to stop and he kept
[__] her so they shipped him off to
Buffalo dude I was at an Applebees and I
overheard the booth behind me apparently
it was the guy's lawyer telling you dude
there was internal problems in the
locker room I heard him the wide
receivers coach lives on my
block I overheard him he was having a
cup of
coffee he said the quarterback knocked
up one of the
cheerleaders dead ass the thing I hate
most when people say that
dead ass oh
Jesus Oh dead ass how funny is that
hearing that coming out of my mouth
[__] dead ass dude yeah hey Paul you
don't want this smoke oh that's the
worst or like you know what kills me how
about every time anybody makes anything
musical they have to have the Jay-Z meme
where he's got the glasses nod in his
head like when do people think that's
going to be funny what JZ me this this
meme where he's he's [__] he's got
his glasses on he's [__] nodding his
head just going like this and it's
always off for some shitty music oh
every [__] time you remember when
YouTube first came out and everybody was
this film with a potato how many [__]
times okay the first time it's funny
[__] 10 years later is this film with
a potato laughing my ass off not asking
for that smoke dead
ass
uh andreww I don't know my picture there
it is there it is Paul that every
[__] time every single [__] time
there's a song out look at it that's
great that's
great hey did you go to the Jay-Z
exhibit out in uh
Brooklin no I don't go to Brooklyn [__]
okay no I'm not a Brooklyn fan I don't
like the Brooklyn Nets I don't like that
all these [__] people that never even
knew what real Brooklyn was is acting
like I mean Where Brooklyn at go
Brooklyn oh dude you don't like it's
safe for all those beta male standup
comedians that live out
there somebody goes dude somebody goes
you should do a show in Brooklyn and I
saw the lineups and I'm like yeah nah
not doing that not doing it I know cuz
you're going to go out there and you're
going to try to have a good show and and
what's funny is is those liberal [__]
are going to so judge you the second you
walk on stage I had that happen in
Brooklyn one and then it's yeah like
yeah the open-minded liberals I yeah uh
what's his name back in the day had that
room at the Knitting Factory Hannibal
burus and I went and did it and I
remember I'm like yeah so I got married
I got a couple kids anybody and I
remember I remember like one woman was
standing there in a scarf looking at me
and when I said you have a family
anybody got a family that she was
like almost like you're on your [__]
own and I wanted to go I wanted to go oh
oh so your parents are paying for that
Brownstone in Williamsburg and I'm the
[__] [__] I'm the [__] you will
mainstream Paulie
I still
am hey Bill what what's what's wrong
with living on Main
Street what's wrong what what's what's
wrong with it um Andrew what are my
picks dude oh what what did I take oh I
took the Lions I took the Raiders who
else did I take Paul I don't know if
this is the coffee talking but I am
having a great time I got the Dolphins
are you I am I'm being a [__] idiot
this week I thought you
were nine and a half maybe it's because
my tour's over Paul and I am I I don't
have any [__] road dates until uh
until the Super
Bowl Super
Bowl okay no I got the Raiders not the
Chiefs I got the Dolphins I got the
Lions and and what else do I have
another pick or no just dropped my cell
phone oh and I got the Broncos got it
got it thank you Jak oh good it's still
working thank you Jake The Snake I mean
see Jake The Snake is just has one more
pick what do you mean I have one more
pick I picked the [__] Eagles I
picked the Texans I picked the Ravens
all right you're right all right let me
get the
Browns in honor of Paul in honor of Paul
V's Brown [__] hide in the desert
we're gonna go head-to-head here why who
do you got I got the
Broncos oh yeah the Broncos AR gonna win
again minus two and a half Hough Russell
I'm looking at a rough week here
guys well what's a rough week for you
Paul two and two no and three one and
three 0 and four no you haven't gone 0
and four the whole year yeah I did week
two you did
yeah you did I was down dude did you I
was down but never out never [__] out
Paul you [__] dug a
hole and they were calling for your
job and then you went on a [__] tear
and then all of those people all of
those people that sent you
tweets what kind of a jerk off would
call Twitter
X I hate that you know what I mean it's
just I had it's like it's it's the
staple center it's not the Bitcoin
[__] fugazi crypto [__] whatever
the [__] they're calling it it's the
Staple Center it's Lambo
field it should be called none of it
should be businesses it should be called
a Coliseum it should be called The
Garden it should be called the memorial
the should be named after a beer that's
as far as you go like the Patriots used
to play in schaer stadium what's that
worst one smoothie Smoothie King Arena
no the worst one ever was was the
jobbing.com
something like that jobs.com Arena where
the Phoenix Coyotes
played when me and Joe bartnik sat at
Sofi where we sat and I looked around
that place dude that place you called me
after you went there the first time I
saw those pillars and it made me think
of the Roman Empire or whatever when you
said that and I was just like I'm
in dude it looks like a [__] Stingray
it's on unbelievable you're coming up to
it and you get inside it when I walked
inside and I just looked all around I
felt like I was on mushrooms it was nuts
it's like is that a green screen or
those really fans that but I will say
you're still way far away I was waiting
and they just pump every Stadium's
pumping crowd noise in like the level of
loud that they are I bring [__]
earplugs to a football game like I'm at
a a concert granted I'm old as [__] dude
when I looked up we were sitting there I
looked up and I saw the levels I was
waiting for Russell Crow's character and
uh the Gladiator are you're not
entertained just throw a sword at the uh
or the what's it called is there
anything more worse than when a football
player yells that to the crowd or the
UFC fighters do too yeah are you well
yeah I'll go with UFC because they're
actually Gladiators you know they're
actually pouring blood yeah you're
pouring blood down yeah I guess yeah it
is a little hacky but I can go with that
but when an NFL player you know [__]
catches a [__] touch catches a pass
and scores a touchdown and then yells
are you not
entertained who did that first was it
Jay-Z on one of his
albums why would you ever align yourself
like yeah I'm at the same level as as
what a guy who holds family yeah you
defeated a [__]
lion yeah with what a letter opener I
mean that yet like you're on that
level are you not
entertained up there rhyming
words oh my oh Paul everybody's getting
it this
week what are you doing for said that
big Jay-Z fan and I went to his uh that
that thing they had out there in
Brooklyn you know what was the best part
was a self-made man I love the self-made
man because it makes you feel like you
can do it too I'm hacking up a lung this
week Paul I swear to God every time I
[__] come off the road I'm a little
bit sick and then my kids I don't know
what's going around no there's a all the
kids are getting that what's a called
that that my son comes in my room every
morning get Dad can I have waffles like
coughs right in my face and then it's it
I'm
done um what are you guys are you guys
hosting you host this year no Paul I
headline you're not here my headline I
carved the
turkey I carve the turkey too yeah I'm
good at carving it I figured it out it
took me three years I finally got it
finally got on YouTube it shows you how
to do it oh yeah I just kind of
oh Jesus oh it's a murder scene no the
first year was I got it I figured it out
it's a murder
scene I just pictur you slice it in half
the other way some people dude one this
one [__] you just go in the other room
can you just go in the other room I know
it's messy I'm gonna clean it up no one
guy flattened it dude it was like the
way he broke it no the chef he like
broke it down and flattened it and did
it and dude it was like the neatest
thing ever uh um yeah yeah I'm excited
though man I got uh got some family
members coming got some family members
not coming um so it's gonna be uh it's
gonna be um a nice it'll be a nice thing
we got we're hosting yeah you know I got
the usual I got the family I got the
relatives I got a couple of comics you
know it's gonna be good but these are
Comics you love obviously yes yeah I
don't like that that's the one thing
about Thanksgiving we're talking about
it before it's like I don't like those
people that brings stranger he got he
had nowhere to go it's like well I don't
know it's my [__] oh dude that's the
[__] worst he had nowhere go flag
he's got nowhere to go because he's an
[__] and it's like this it's like
he's a wild card I don't know him I
don't know what he's gonna say nobody
knows him and then I look like I'm doing
the good deed and then all of a sudden
my family members are on eggshells
because it's some [__] you gotta go in
your bedroom and hide your watch no no
it's not happen you're not coming to my
house you're not gonna be around my kids
it's just not gonna happen it's not
gonna happen dude not with me he's got
nowhere to go well guess what he still
has nowhere to go
guess what my got a place to go the [__]
on out of here yeah and I don't like
those people they act like they're hey I
was wondering can I friend he's got
nowhere ah sorry not enough hey Paul
when you finish carving the turkey can
you yell at you not entertained to your
wife and kids oh my God I'll just hold
the Carver up yeah are you not
entertained look at it no in the middle
of everybody eating just slam your hand
down and then just stare at them is it
like what the [__] just be like I'm just
kidding yeah I just wanted to you know
just say what I'm thankful for this year
and then you just go Hallmark after that
yeah I don't you know you know what else
I don't like I don't like the I don't
like the person that says Grace too long
for them it's for them you know I don't
mind Grace unless it starts with
heavenly
father that's when you know it's going
to be long no but there are extra
religious heav father no the ones that
do it self you're supposed to [__]
say it quick you're supposed to say it
and mean it but the ones that like
prolong and we know that we know that
all of people that aren't here with us
then people start getting sad it's like
Jesus [__] it's not a it's not a eulogy
right and then and then if somebody at
the table's going through a problem we
know Jeff is going through we pray that
Jeff gets through this and Jeff's just
holding a knife and
for he's waiting you know Jeff uh
thought that massage parlor was legal
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey M let's stay on topic here come on
come on his his mother's here come on I
had a shoulder
issue his wife's a little erratic you
should have listen to me oh God Heavenly
[Laughter]
Father oh I was in a bad mood you put me
in a silly mood I'm in a oh my God me
and all have been joking about you know
the friend you have that threatens that
they're going to kill themselves but you
know they're not and it just gets
exhausting talking him off the [__]
ledge yeah that's the funny and then we
were just saying like because neither
one of us is goingon to do the bit and
like you just called it Bluff oh yeah
you don't got the balls yeah no yeah
dude hey do me a favor do me a favor
call me when after you did it yeah no
but they always start off where they
want you to say oh no don't say that
they'll go like this they'll go ah dude
I don't give up [__] anymore who knows
if I'm even going to [__] they start who
knows if I'm going to be around and then
you're looking at it and they want you
to go hey man come on dude do you need
me and it's no but you do the first
1,400 [__] times and then you're like
wait a minute
yeah am I Charley Brown trying to kick
the [__] ball here no but you had the
hey man you know there's a lot of
traffic out there if you want to be one
less [__] car no you had the best one
where you just go you don't have the
balls dude that one that text is cuz it
was would just confuse them they would
be confused they would be like what dude
I don't have the balls you don't got it
in
you we're still doing before [__]
people come at us I've had friends that
have killed themselves but you know what
I mean I've also had friends that
threaten to kill themselves and you
[__] got to go through all those
[__] emotions and all it is is they
they're just having a [__] narcissist
moment where they need attention or
whatever it is I'm not talk to Phil if
anybody took that seriously watching
this then kill yourself I'm kidding uh
no I'm just
no I'm saying like it it it makes we're
actually saying that we're good friends
that feel concerned dud I I'm not lying
I had a friend say that going hey man I
don't know if I'm gonna and I literally
was like dude don't say that like I'm
here for you and it puts you in the
situation but then when they do it like
you said multiple times I'm going who am
I talking to here dude this isn't
healthy for any [__] body go get help
and stop doing it to me because I
[__] love you and I don't want God
forbid that happens um boy that yeah I
mean after like is there a rule like how
many times can someone threaten to kill
themselves like they should be like a
punch card you know we get like a free
video back in the day like a if they
start Bill what if they start saying it
you go no you're
not oh this
again you said that three months ago
you're still here I'll tell you right
now if you threaten to kill yourself one
more time you don't do it I'm gonna
[__] kill
myself I'll kill you and me it'll be a
murder of suicide you [__] [__]
you want me to help you because I'm sick
of you you just no you just look around
to all your friends as he's saying it
you
go
no he's okay I'll talk I'll
talk you know what these jokes are for
Paul the people that have to [__] go
through it every time they say it all
right they deserve jokes too it's
exhausting it's exhausting it's
emotionally exhausting because you love
the person and they [__] do that and
there's something in your mind that goes
maybe one time they do it and it's
[__] sad and by the way if anybody
has issues like that call the hotline
talk everybody knows that Paul you don't
have the [__] everybody knows that
everybody knows that I know but you scar
everybody knows that who doesn't think
about killing
themselves I mean when I was you always
have the
thought like when you're young like a
little quick thing you
know you know what I was afraid no you
know what I was afraid of I was afraid
of like
joking like joking with a rope like and
then all of a sudden like you slip
you're like no I didn't mean I didn't
[__] mean it dude I hell you know
like even though you wouldn't be able to
scream that yeah I was gonna say if if
you can yell that I think you're all
right or like drowning in two inches you
know what a big one of mine Fear Factor
did this one thing dude the one Fear
Factor that still haunts me to this day
I don't care about eating cow balls I
don't care about the insects and the
Tarantulas and all that the one thing
that [__] still makes me every time
is the car that went into into a
swimming pool and the guy had to get out
and he was just and and like there were
like divers there in case he couldn't
but like you're strapped in a seat belt
you get submerged and then you had to do
it and get out dude for me oh my God
that for me dude being underwater in a
car in that little of water freaks me
that's like the number one thing that
they hit for me right you know well and
then you know there's that guy there's
that guy here's this guy you're gonna
love this no I know how to do that
listen you gotta wait and then open the
guy that acts calm like he knows what to
do you wait for it to be submerged and
then you go and swim out it's not that
big of a deal it's like it's like yeah
okay yeah I don't get that you gotta
wait till the pressure equalizes well
how do I do that it's not a pressurized
C cabin it's a [__] car maybe through
the vents it gets equal I don't know
yeah nobody knows I mean unless I feel
like you just well my thing is if you
have electric windows that's what sucks
about electric windows is if you go
in how do you get the windows to go down
you got to be like when you're in the
the air like Dukes of Hazard let me get
my hand here like Dukes of Hazard that's
when you [__] you're like ah you got
to put the [__] window down as you're
going I'm gonna tell you something
really stupid I did please don't judge
me I know you will I used to be afraid
to go over Bridges like when I was like
so what I would do is I would drive over
a bridge and as soon as I started
driving over a big bridge I would take
my seat Bel off and put all the windows
down so if it did fall into the water in
my mind I'm not strapped in and I could
just jump out of the thing and then as
soon as I would get over the bridge all
the windows come up and I'd strap back
in it's more OCD than anything else I
mean I don't know there's people that
have been thrown from cars and lived
there's other people there was a whole
band everybody
died except the one guy was wearing a
seat Bel he had minor injuries and the
whole [__] band died because they
were in a van and it
rolled it's a b MGM show everybody it's
B MGM show people we talking suicide
we're talking
of things here 19 people I think they
said out of 2,000 and some people that
jumped over the Golden Gate Bridge in
San Francisco 19 of them survived and
all 19 that survived said as soon as
they went over they were like ah [__] I
shouldn't be doing this oh wait it's not
that
bad yeah the guy was like broke every
bone in his body and he said he like
talked about on a documentary he was
like as soon as I jumped I was like the
[__] dude you know
but
that's
what I'm just thinking of that as the
wind starts whistling as you're picking
up speed I still don't get how water
turns into concrete after it's like it's
not as it can't be as bad as concrete
because you still go into it you don't
just like bounce no but dude a belly
flop off of a diving board [__] hurts
man so why can't you go on feet first
point your toes like Greg lukus well
what's his name David blae
David Blaine went on Conan years ago
when Conan show was in New York and uh I
almost said rest your soul like just
because the show's gone but anyway so he
said to Conan he's like yeah you know
the way David Blaine talks he goes yeah
Conan I'm like he like that [__] and he
goes if you actually jump off of like
the Brooklyn Bridge because he wanted to
jump off the Brooklyn Bridge he said if
you drop something first and it causes a
little bit of a splash or Ripple you can
go through that so I'm thinking about
we're thinking about dropping something
in front of me and I'm going to jump up
to Brooklyn Bridge and I remember Conan
just going why would you do that and
everybody got really like a big laugh
but he never he never ended up doing it
because there's too much room for error
there's too much room for error there I
met that guy one time David Blaine yeah
hey Bill funny immediately he was doing
like a trick and he was just what's your
favorite card I was just gon like have
have we ever have we ever met have we
ever met before it's like dude just do
your [__] trick all right I know you
don't really know you're not really
magical
the fact that he felt that he also had
to like distract me with his [__]
bedroom voice was annoying to me because
I'm just like I I I'm not going to be
able to figure out what you do you throw
cards and the [__] thing sticks to
the other side of the window I don't
know how you do that but if you could
actually Paul if you could actually do
that how quickly the CIA would pick you
up and drive you to wherever they have
the aliens yeah that would be it he was
on he was on Jimmy Fallon and he had the
roots and Jimmy Fallon losing it because
he goes Jimmy I want you to think of an
amphibian and and goes all right a frog
and he goes hold on and he just starts
drinking water and he spits up a frog
and everybody I mean the roots ran
everybody went nothing it's like yeah
what he did was he had a frog sitting in
his he drank like five or six glasses of
water he had a frog sitting there went
up did the trick regurgitated the Frog
into a thing and everybody was like What
if he said a lizard what what if he said
a lizard I know but I I think their part
of their thing is to lead you to say
when he went to Harrison for he goes
Harrison pick a fruit it's like [__]
big Orange right
there I wonder where the card is I know
and then he [__] takes the card out
of it took the card out of and Harrison
for you did you see
Harris get the [__] out of my
house yeah I don't understand why they
get like it's just like wow that's some
I don't know when you did
that but it's like it's the same trick
where they can get you to pick the card
here they just stick it in the [__]
orange I will tell you this dude card
tricks I kind of like because you know
it's a trick but it's dude Jimmy
Schubert comedian Jimmy Schubert's a
magician and we were in Vegas and dude
he did [__] he [__] me up with one
of those things he I took a card and
then he showed me an Altoids container
and he opened the Altoids container he
never moved his hands I saw everything
he did and he had all the these Altoids
in the container and then he closed it
and then he [__] opened it later and
it was empty and it had the card in it
and I was like that's a [__] cool
trick now I know it's a great trick but
that's a great trick but when like David
Jimmy Schubert's not magical he is when
he's on stage though nobody is that's
what I'm saying it's stupid David Blaine
did like a pay-per-view and he was
supposed to jump and it like it was a
big [__] up the crane dropped them slow
there was a crane like that makes
building they they use for buildings and
it was like hooked up to him and he went
down slow and it just went to black and
it was like a he's like yeah things
didn't work out it's like yeah like
walked on water everyone went nuts and
they found out that it was just a clear
table on top of it you can't walk on
there no no that was Chris Angel he was
walking on water and people like oh
people dude I'll be honest some oh my
God stealing money dude yeah we went to
that thing dude and I I mean listen God
bless him but we went to that Vegas show
for Chris Angel that mind freak thing
Think Jesus was watching going hey hey
hey this [__] guy that's
[__] dad he's using a table they got
all stunt doubles and [__] that look
exactly like him a big poof and then
they transport they teleport and he's
there and every was like how did you
move
from all right anyway you know what time
it is Bill it's time for oh I know what
time the Monday night special
back win some money for you
let the Monday night
special win some [__] money for you
you know Paul I was thinking you know
what's a good bet is when one team has a
good
defense meaning a great defense yeah you
know they're gonna go bellich They're
gonna take away their first option so
then if you're gonna guess touchdown I
kind of was thinking about that watching
the Chiefs because he threw that other
guy that 84 whatever the hell his name
is Rex Reed I don't know what his name
is but like I'm saying Patrick Mahomes
because they were doubling Kelce in the
beginning but Kelce ended up Breaking
Free and he still caught a touchdown but
I was thinking like yeah why wouldn't I
think that they would double Kelce and
the would lead this it's like all right
you're G to beat us with the number two
receiver I'm just saying I think the
number two receiver sometimes if you got
a good quarterback with a good offensive
line against a good defense you pick the
number two receiver because they're
probably going to double the first guy
that's all I'm trying to say here Paul I
agree I think it's a nice Theory oh I'm
glad you're said that cuz if you didn't
I was going to kill myself you don't got
the
balls uh all right we got Vikings minus
three and a half at
home that's why you open with that joke
you know and then Thanksgiving you know
you always got that one guess you know
that guy's always threatening to kill
himself do that out in
Brooklyn all right go ahead yeah uh get
ahead Paul get ahead I don't like I
don't like the guest that that you that
you you know the the family member he's
kind of like a distant one and you go
hey man how you doing how you been and
you got a glass of wine and you're happy
for the holiday and they just go man
it's been all right you know it's like I
don't I didn't really want the real
[__] thing dude you know what be
great Paul if you just just walk away oh
my God and they'll know why and and that
won't be a [__] thing just walk away
and then turn around look at him and
just laugh that's
great um Paul please do that this just
if it happens just walk away everybody
listening to this if you got that person
and go well you know things have been
look could be better you it was a uh it
was a tough year and just [__] the
voice changed the voice yeah you know
listen dud Z to what can you do D trying
to figure it out you just walk away
listen Paul I'm really happy for you you
have a beautiful family everything seems
to be working out I mean unfortunately I
can't say the same thing for myself you
know three months ago and you just
[__] walk
away I came here to eat turkey and watch
football not listen to your the results
of your [__]
decisions all right guys we got the
Vikings at home uh uh you know saying
all right guys is actually sexist you
might want to think about that all right
let's go about all right people um um
Vikings are minus three and a half uh
the under over is 3 uh I'm sorry
43 uh dude the Vikings lost that
Heartbreaker at the very end to Denver
but still covered why the [__] why the
[__] are bears getting all this respect
are they are they playing now they're
starting to play a little better three
and a half Paul the half the half the
half it's the name of this episode well
they lost last week I think they were a
better team and I like that kid dos
playing quarterback I think the Vikings
win the game by a touchdown let's take
the
Vikings I think they're up by a
touchdown and they're going to [__]
scare the [__] out of us all right let's
do that you want to go over you want to
do over 43 or no root for some points or
nah [__] Bears are anemic yeah I
don't believe in the Bears until they
win another Super
Bowl well you're the special guy dude
because your specials are
on we've only won once this year so
let's let's go easy with the come Paul I
gotta tell you I me know you just been
having a real tough time with the
special you know uh yeah I was just you
know [__] at my job first year we hit
like five of them in
you know I I don't know Paul where'd you
go um you do DOS I will take uh I don't
know man it's like I like that kid and
stuff but I mean he's still learning
that [__] this his third offense he's
learning this
year um yeah but he's good he's a rocket
scientist like legit well great he's
playing football
Paul we're not try to go to out of SP
space I'm trying to get some [__]
points here he knows a
Playbook uh gronowski was not a rocket
scientist he was [__] an amazing
football player we're playing football
here yeah that's great dude that's a
great joke when people go yeah dude
that's a smart kid dude did you hear
he's like a scientist in the off season
yeah how many scientists do you know can
play
football
um so what do you want we both like the
Vikings to win the game by four or more
right and what's what's the over under
43 let's go over because everyone's
going to think it's going to suck all
right so we'll do Vikings and over and
we need one
more uh what's the over under that they
bring up that he's actually a scientist
before the second quarter can we bet on
that I would say definitely two times
let's take the over I mean you have to
bet 900 to make a
thousand um Paul you pick the next
thing they got a decent running back
Vikings Paulie can you hear me I think
Josh dobs throws one dude all right good
he looked he had that look when he
walked off when when Russell Wilson beat
him at the last minute he had the look
on his face of like when he was saying
like his congratulations to the other
team he had the look like dude I I'm not
happy I think he's going to come out he
had that looked like it doesn't compute
like he was looking at a graduated
cylinder of liquid
and the information there did not match
what was on his paper yeah do you think
do you think he reads the Playbook and
he's so smart he just goes
next what else do you remember that was
another dumb thing speed readers that
was another [__] I remember a guy
doing it on the news oh no what's happen
oh God and then oh he was like reacting
to what he was reading and just going
like through it's just like you went out
you got the cliff notes you stuck the
Ace of Spades in the orange before you
went to [__] and Harrison I mean come
on it's breaking and entering and then
you do a card trick Paul yeah because
here's the real here's the reality bill
you can't make a card appear in
Fruit uh yeah no one has that
ability dude I had people you buy the
orange at a magic shop you gotta pay for
it and then they tell you how to [__]
do it I I talked to a magician who
showed me he's like yeah you they cut it
and if you notice when they cut it it's
not a full cut cuz it's already [__]
cut so they just go like this and they
open it it's ridiculous it's it's
perfectly cut dude I had a dumb guy go
dude Chris Angel dude that could be
Jesus dude but we were freaking out me
and my wife like he might and I'm like
yeah it's it's on TV dude it's a camera
you should have said to him please tell
me the two of you haven't made
children yeah I don't think they did
either um thank God all right so there
we go wow this has been a fun one people
were loving the last one they're going
to love this one this one was oh this
one was silly oh Paul we went all over
the road here oh we suicide [__]
magic tricks that's right driving over
[Music]
brid hey yeah if Bruce Springstein can
how come I can't hear
you I can't hear you Paulie can you hear
me can oh all right I'm gonna wrap it up
I'll wrap it up Paul I'll wrap it up hey
this has been the anything better
podcast and my gift to you is that look
of confusion on Paul ver face he tries
to figure out his
audio uh go can you hear me now yes
we're very thankful for all of you that
have been watching the podcast we're so
happy that we we hit one special this
year we we do really do take that
seriously I mean I want to make our
listeners money more than I mean I don't
give a [__] if I win or lose I want them
to win you know yes we love the specials
um and this week you got a possibility
here you got you got the Vikings doing
my homecoming Theory a good team losing
on the road they're coming home they
gota win by four Joshy dobs I don't know
why I called him Joshy Josh dobs is
going to throw a touchdown and you know
what we're gonna root for some points
let's get 44 points and um there you go
so that's the Monday night special and
um we hope from our families to yours
you guys have a happy healthy
Thanksgiving gamble responsibly throw in
10 bucks here 20 bucks there by the way
the B MGM app just throw in 10 they're
going to give you up to 200 good time to
do it it's Thanksgiving not bad catching
a little scratch for Thanksgiving you
got three games by the way how about
this real quick before we get out of
here the NFL doing a Black Friday Jets
Dolphins game I'm not gonna lie it's
nice to have four games this four G uh
four week four days this week of
football I mean they're trying to break
up marriages they're gonna [__] show
three games on
Thursday right three gny you said you
were gonna cut to Turkey hang on a
second all right and then they got the
Black Friday game then you got Michigan
and Ohio State on Saturday all the
rivalry games Alabama Auburn getting
after it tell your mother to cut it tell
your mother H this is one of the
greatest weekends ever if you're not in
a relationship Wednesday night you go
down to the local place all the hotties
that you knew from high school you chat
them up hey maybe you get lucky show up
like a [__] idiot to somebody's
Thanksgiving thing you know you got a
bottle of booze I'm saying if you're
younger Paul this is for younger people
right then watch three [__] football
games Black
Friday unreal you know you get to watch
video of people getting trampled at a
big box store then you get to watch a
game you got the college football
rivalries then you got football Sunday
and you got Monday I mean what else do
these people want I mean it's all it is
and I guarantee you they're gonna pass
something in the Senate that they don't
want us to see that's why they got all
these games Paul Bill Bill ask me like
uh ask me if I'm excited for the this
weekend hey man you see all these games
three three [__] on Thanksgiving and
they even got one on uh Black Friday man
you gotta be psyched right yeah you know
I guess I got things at work going on
man so it's just
[Music]
like all right all listeners that's how
you do it this weekend I want like I
swear to God I don't give a [__] if your
wife is saying something cuz she'll
laugh that is just so [__] rid that's
such a ridiculous move out of nowhere
hey can I talk to you for a second okay
C's here and she just really so to me
you just [__] walk away no
no tell me you put your dog down and
when she gets mad just laugh don't
engage don't argue just laugh why are
you walking away from me hey you ever
think maybe you ever think maybe it's my
Thanksgiving too yeah and you know what
you know what's women you don't get
along with each
other well yeah you know what's
underrated too that people don't utilize
enough Bill the look Paul's coming hard
I can feel this no the look you know how
about can't just people have the look me
and Stacy have the look because we sit
across from each other so I'm at the
head I'm at the head of the table here
she's at the head Paul you're in charge
yeah yeah hey it's my it's my thing you
so no like everybody everybody's lined
up here right so you have all the people
down the down the table I'm at the head
and Stacy's at the head when somebody
does something we don't like you know
mean Stacy do we just go like this
go that's it let's go okay you know
that's it and then brows is a lot
eyebrows get you caught yeah eyebrows
yeah you can't go eyebrows eyebrows get
you caught this is what I this this this
is look I'll give you a look okay
somebody says something [__] up say
something [__] up Paul go we're at the
table eating I tell you dude the problem
really is the all these [__] migrants
coming in and that's what everybody's
taking everybody's
job that's it
[Laughter]
you just look up you find your [__]
friend yeah and you just hold it for a
second and a half it's just too long and
then you just look and they know then
what they do is this what they do then
they got the napkin they're going like
because you know what it is too though
Bill the person that says that they
don't even realize that you could agree
with what they're saying it's just not
the time dude it's not the time because
everybody knows there's somebody at the
table that doesn't agree dude I I'm
going to say this I know they're not
going to listen dude I was at the table
at my Thanksgiving table once and dude
somebody at the table was talking about
people that are like special needs and
he kind of alluded to the fact he wasn't
immediate family but he just goes Yeah
man they should just have like an asylum
for them dude they should just put them
in like a and dude somebody goes what
and and and then I oh no then my
mother-in-law was like what no just no
and he's like no but I'm saying like if
they had a place to go and she's going
please stop dude and I'm just eating my
[__] cranberry sauce and it kind of
diffused but it was like I mean the dude
just basically said if you're if
somebody's going through that their
special needs they should just have them
in a place and and and I'm like dude all
right that that's like lifetime not in
like you're not
invited because that every every year
he's gonna say something
stupid yeah yeah uh the look your look
was good hey Bill you're a good actor I
got a good look I got a good look you
can't do eyebrows eyebrows get you
caught yeah you can get caught in the
middle of an eyebrow thing then you got
to turn it into a yawn or a thing if you
do this you gota be like no no no you
talk about the food if you get caught if
you go like this like I'll do it if I'll
go like if I get caught though this is
me getting caught if you just go you
know I have the worst athletes foot and
I just I was itching it right before I
sat
down dude those
potatoes
those this dude that gravy um how many
you got how many you got coming we got
10 coming you got more than 10 I don't
know I don't do the guest list I invited
a couple of buddies of
mine um can't go more than 15 on
Thanksgiving it's the number that's the
number dude yeah well you gotta have a
couple of buddies to come over us to
offset yes you know whatever's going to
be going
on so you got can peel off and gives
listen you know I I'd love to help but I
got to go uh I gotta
ENT all right let's wrap this thing up
all right guys this was an extended one
uh thank you guys so much check it out
download the app $10 get you 200
regardless outcome of your of your bet
enjoy bet responsibly Happy Thanksgiving
from our show to you guys to our
families to you guys enjoy football
tomorrow everybody and we will see you
next week for week 13 on the anything
better podcast take care and I want to
hear from people if they walked away
dairo in heat You Gotta Be You got to
walk away you got to write into the show
and let us know if you walked away from
negative Nelly y I'm doing it all right
I'm walking away all right guys we'll
see
you